weil in dreierlei hinsicht ein signal
der stabilität und verlässlichkeit davon
ausgeht was machen wir im einzelnen
erster diesem renten paket setzen wir
eine kräftige rentenerhöhung zum ersten
juli um das ist die kräftigste
rentenerhöhung seit vielen jahrzehnten
die renten steigen zum ersten juli in
deutschland im westen um 5,3 prozent und
im osten auf 6,1 prozent
meine damen und herren dass es gerade in
diesen zeiten ein wichtiges signal
es folgt der lohn- und
gehaltsentwicklung und ist auch ein
zeichen des stabilität des
arbeitsmarktes
es ist wichtig dass die renten kräftig
in diesem jahr steigen
zweitens wir sorgen aber auch die
stabilität im system geben das prinzip
der rentengarantie des nach höhe des
faktors sorgt im prinzip dafür dass wir
in krisenzeiten dafür sorgen dass renten
leben nicht gekürzt werden müssen und
den guten zeiten die einen fairen
interessenausgleich zwischen
rentnerinnen und rentnern und
beitragszahlern organisieren und
drittens was mir besonders am herzen
liegt was endlich erreicht werden kann
ist wir sorgen für deutliche
verbesserungen für erwerbsgeminderte
bürgerinnen und bürger jeden menschen
mit dem menschen und dem nicht mehr oder
nur eingeschränkt arbeiten können weil
sie beispielsweise an einem krebsleiden
oder einer schweren nervenerkrankungen
erkrankt sind oder weil sie schwere
behinderungen haben diese menschen zu
unterstützen weil der damen und herren
es eine frage der verantwortung und der
gerechtigkeit und das ist mir ein
herzensanliegen dass wir das endlich
elisa koalition hinbekommen der
vorgänger koalition war das leider noch
nicht möglich
lassen sie mich zu den einzelnen punkten
ausführen aber vorweg eins sagen mir ist
aufgefallen als für den gesetzentwurf
veröffentlicht haben gab es
agenturmeldung und agenturmeldungen
müssen immer bebildert werden und
agenturen suchen dann in deutschland
immer stock fotos aus so heißt es um
themen zu gebilden mir ist aufgefallen
dass wenn über rente und rentnerinnen
und rentner
berichtet wird diese stock fotos dann
auf rentnerinnen und rentner zeigen die
entweder auf einer parkbank sitzenden
braun gebrannt sind oder beenden und
renten aber im golfen zeigen ich will
das mal ganz entsetzlich was sagen die
meisten rentnerinnen rentner in
deutschland leben nicht in saus und
braus und ich sage sehr deutlich ich
kenne viel viel mehr rentnerinnen ränder
die minigolf spielen als welche die sich
golf leisten können und austragen
das wenn rentnerinnen und rentner nach
leben voller arbeit war auf der parkbank
sitzen sie meistens viele jahrzehnte
vorher an der werkbank oder an der
supermarktkasse gearbeitet haben auch
das darf man nicht vergessen deshalb zum
ersten die rentenerhöhung die jetzt zum
ersten juli kommt die es keine gnaden
geschenk des staates das ist ergebnis
von lebensleistung und der tatsache dass
es in deutschland die rentenerhöhung der
lohn- und gehaltsentwicklung in dem
arbeitsmarkt folgen und weil wir es
geschafft haben in der kroner pandemie
den deutschen arbeitsmarkt trotz allem
mit kurzarbeit und ähnlichen stabil zu
halten und weil es letztes jahr
ordentliche lohnabschlüsse gab ist diese
rentenerhöhung von 5,1 prozent im westen
und 6,3
5,3 prozent im westen und 61 prozent im
osten möglich das würde ich sagen das
ist nicht ein geschenk das ist verdient
meine therapie
und zweitens zum thema nachholfaktor und
rentengarantie auch das muss man
erklären dass die technische begriffe im
kern geht es darum dass wir im jahre
2020 am beginn der pandemie einen
wirtschaftlichen einbruch erlebt haben
auch ein einbruch bei den löhnen der
dazu geführt hätte dass statistisch ein
jahr später
2021 die renten hätten gekürzt werden
dass aus guten gründen machen wir das in
deutschland nicht und das ganze nennt
sich rentengarantie das ist die eine
seite der medaille die andere seite der
medaille ist dass in zeiten dienst
besser läuft für daneben einen fairen
interessenausgleich zwischen
rentnerinnen und rentnern
beitragszahlern leisten auch das
stabilisiert das system und ich glaube
es ist eine frage der verlässlichkeit
und drittens zu der erwerbsgemindert
meine damen und herren wir haben es in
den letzten jahren seit 2014 geschafft
bei den erwerbsminderungsrenten zu
verbesserungen zu kommen schritt für
schritt unter meiner amtsvorgängerin
andrea nahles auch in meiner letzten
legislaturperiode als
bundesarbeitsminister in der großen
koalition allerdings nur für zukünftige
fälle und die meisten schreiben als
abgeordnete haben wir immer bekommen von
erwerbsgeminderten die schule bestand
sind die arbeiten wollten aber die
erkrankt sind die in der arbeits leben
zum teil verunfallt sind die einfach
wollten aber nicht mehr konnten und ich
bin froh dass du jetzt für drei
millionen erwerbsgeminderte in
deutschland zu deutlichen verbesserungen
kommune damen und herren das zeigt auch
die leistungsfähigkeit der solidarität
der gesetzlichen rentenversicherung
diese drei schritte sind wichtig und ich
weiß was nachher in der debatte
passieren wird es wird welche geben die
sagen ist alles schön und gut aber wir
haben im moment massive
preissteigerungen und richtig wir
verkennen überhaupt nicht welche sorgen
sich viele bürgerinnen und bürger auch
wenn trainer in deutschland machen und
dann wird es einige aus der opposition
geben die wiederum wie gestern behaupten
im entlastungspaket den 30 milliarden
die die koalition auf den weg gebracht
hat sei nichts drin für rentnerinnen und
rentner da sage ich sehr deutlich das
ist falsch ich finde sie sollten richtig
sein
weil der kollege straubinger sie ist
besser wissen ich will es ihnen mal ganz
deutlich sagen erstens profitieren
natürlich auch rentnerinnen und rentnern
von den allgemeinen entlastung wie der
abschaffung der eeg umlage
zweitens profitieren rentnerinnen und
rentner natürlich auch davon dass für
kraftstoff preise senken und mit dem
neuen euro ticket ermöglichen dass
mobilität bezahlbar bleiben drittens
wird auch der grundfreibetrag erhöht
auch das ist etwas von dem rentnerinnen
und rentner profitieren können und
natürlich ist es auch so dass in den
grundsicherungssystem mit dem 200 euro
zuschlag auch menschen der
grundsicherung im alter profitieren
genauso übrigens meine damen und herren
wie von der tatsache dass wir mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
zu 50 prozent übrigens rentnerinnen und
rentner erreichen also wir können gerne
mit mir darüber streiten ob es genug ist
aber dass nichts zur anderen renten an
diesen paketen ist stimmt nicht und sie
sollten das auch schon
einmal damit lernen mit diesem renten
paket 1 sorgen dass die stabilität und
verlässlichkeit und bitte den
leistungspaketen machen wir in
schwierigen zeiten das leben für viele
menschen ein stück einfacher will an
dieser stelle aber auch sagen nicht nur
für rentnerinnen und rentner falls und
wenn die preissteigerung ganz lange
dauern würden dann werden wir auch
weitere maßnahmen ergreifen auch für
rentnerinnen und rentner dann geht es
aber nicht um einmalige maßnahmen da
muss es um strukturelle entlastung geben
gerade für mittlere und untere einkommen
das ganze ist notwendig sagt das deshalb
weil wir unsere gesellschaft in diesen
schwierigen zeiten zusammenhalten müssen
und deshalb ist die ansage dieser
koalition ganz ganz klar wir werden
dafür sorgen dass unser sozialstaat
funktioniert und wir werden nicht
zulassen dass äußere sicherheit gegen
sozialen frieden im inland ausgespielt
wird so richtig es ist dass wir die
bundeswehr besser ausrüsten es wird
nicht zulasten der sozialen sicherheit
in deutschland geben das ist die klare
ansage dieser koalition herzlichen dank
die bundesminister hubertus heil hat
erläutert was seiner meinung nach den
rentnerinnen und rentner gutes
widerfahren soll ab 20 22 rund 21
millionen sollen profitieren von der
rentenanpassung
2022 und auch die erwerbsminderungsrente
sind ja im blick bei diesem
gesetzentwurf der erste redner aus der
opposition max straubinger
der bundesregierung zur rentenanpassung
nun zur verbesserung der eu dienten also
der erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente und ich
möchte beginnen mit einem zeitlosen satz
der letztendlich zum ausdruck bringt
nämlich die verantwortung union für die
rentenpolitik nämlich aber eins ist
sicher die rente wie es norbert blüm mal
plakatiert hat verehrte damen und herren
und da hat er recht gehabt da hat er
recht gehabt und die union die hat sich
immer an diesen satz orientiert und wenn
der herr bundesminister ist dargelegt
hat dass hier die renten zum ersten juli
steigen werden um 5 35 prozent in west-
und in um 6.12 im osten so ist dies mit
ein ausdruck nämlich der vergangenheit
und dementsprechend der vergangenen
bundesregierung die dafür die grundlagen
gelegt hat nämlich unter angela merkel
unter führenden lohn als das muss
verliert deutlich sagen dass sie als
bundesminister hier dies natürlich auch
mit zu verantworten haben herr kollege
herr bundesminister hat ist völlig mit
klar da stehen wir auch mit dazu aber
wenn wir heute darstellen können dass es
kräftige rentensteigerungen gibt so muss
man schon darauf verweisen dass es
letztes jahr keine rentensteigerung gab
aus bekannten gründen auch des
wirtschaftlichen einbruchs der mit zu
verzeichnen war und dass dies auch mit
nachgeholt wird jetzt auch in dieser
kräftig kite aber das bedeutet ganz
besonders herr bundesminister und sie
haben wir ausführlich noch über das
entlastungspaket ob der
energiepreisentwicklung wird darauf
hingewiesen dass auch die rentnerinnen
und rentner daran teilhaben sollten hier
mit in deutschland unter geht es eben
und die 300 euro für die
energiepreissteigerungen und die
und dies halten sie den rentnerinnen und
rentnern fuhr und so gibt es nicht und
wir als union wir werden darauf drängen
auch in den beratungen das hier
weiterhin auch die rentnerinnen und
rentner genauso mit entlastet werden ist
wie es die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer auch werden es gibt auch
gar keinen sinn der bundesminister und
ich plädiere an ihre soziale
verantwortung
nämlich gut verdienen die arbeitnehmer
in der automobilindustrie zum beispiel
300 euro also mit einer unterstützung zu
geben und den armen rentnern der
möglicherweise keine betriebliche
altersversorgung und gar nichts hat den
herbert es nicht mit also wo ist hier
das sozialpolitische verantwortung der
bundesminister und ich würde sie auch
dann auffordern sich die wenn sie es von
uns und union nicht machen sondern
zumindest dann von ihren ja auch mit in
der partei verankerten quanten also
zumindest die mahnenden worte von verena
bentele oder der ulrike mascher die
einmal staatssekretärin bei der spd
bundestagfraktion wort hier dies mit
aufzunehmen diese mahnenden worte und
dementsprechend die rentnerinnen und
rentner zu unterstützen wir als union
sind dazu bereit fertig
an das zweite ist oben zu recht auch die
verbesserungen bei der
erwerbsminderungsrente
die erwerbsminderungsrente
ist ein wichtiger sozialpolitischer
baustein mit in unserem rentensystem das
gilt es aber dann schon zu hinterfragen
warum wir nur die
erwerbsminderungsrentner beginnend vom
ersten januar 2001 bis 2018 mit einem
pauschalen zuschlag beglücken denn es
gab auch vor
2001 erwerbsminderungsrentner die sogar
die sogar die sogar weniger
zurechnungszeiten damals hatten nämlich
nur bis zum bis 55 jahren also das
bedeutet dass sie hier letztendlich
rentenpolitischen nachholen müssen also
diese frage die muss auch mit gelöst
werden und wie sie dann darauf kommen
dass die einen 7,5 prozent zuschlag
bekommen und die anderen 4,5 prozent
also das hat sich mir noch nicht
erschlossen das sollten sie hier meines
erachtens auch mit darlegen wird
fertig kolleginnen und kollegen spd und
auch der regierungsfraktionen es ist
auch richtig dass dann auch und facto
wieder eingeführt wird also hier hat er
die fdp darauf gedrungen das ist auch
richtig denn wenn die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer weniger
einkommen haben da musste ich dies
leider auch deinen rentnerin rentnern
hier natürlich mit niederschlagen in der
gesetzgebung aber dann muss man es auch
richtig machen wir stehen dafür dass es
sicherlich
hier keine erniedrigung der renten gibt
es ist überhaupt ja völlig klar aber
dann muss es auch nachgeholt werden und
während die kolleginnen und kollegen der
fdp dass sie sich zurück zurücklehnen
und sagen wir haben es ist schon in
ordnung nur weil es im heutigen jahr
klappt aber in zukünftige jahren wird
ihr nachholfaktor sowie der im gesetz
steht keine wirkung erzielen das ist mit
mit diese situation da bin ich schon
erstaunt darüber also das heißt wir
werden noch in den beratungen darauf
intensiv mit eingehen und darauf freue
ich mich herzlicher dank
max straubinger für die unionsfraktion
um genauer zu sein für die csu aus der
csu-landesgruppe hat wieder dort für die
eingangsrede des bundesministers für
arbeit und soziales für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen jetzt markus kurth
in deren sozialpolitik und lampen
experten und kollegen
sehr geehrter herr straubinger bin ich
in der letzten zeit so die reden der
union zum thema sozial und
arbeitsmarktpolitik höre habe ich
irgendwie gemischte gefühle einerseits
freue ich mich ja dass sie nicht
irgendwie jetzt haarscharf den
neoliberalen kurs einschlagen oder
wirtschaftsliberalen sondern tatsächlich
sich zu den prinzipien unseres
sozialstaats auch bekennen und in dem
rahmen argumentieren auf der anderen
seite muss ich mich doch sehr wundern
wie sie jetzt hier quasi uns links
überholen wollen von der ampel und
zusätzliche leistungsausweitungen
fordern die sie alle blockiert haben
doch in den letzten 16 jahren
also zum beispiel
wer hat sie denn wer hat sie denn daran
gehindert das was wir hier in erster
lesung heute ein bringen nämlich
verbesserungen bei der
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand diese
auch vorzunehmen
also ich will dabei gar nicht ich will
dich in abrede stellen dass
sie für neue rentnerinnen und rentner
insgesamt in drei stufen in den letzten
acht jahren verbesserungen in der
erwerbsminderungsrente vorgenommen haben
das team haben wir damals auch
zugestimmt aber für die bestands
rentnerinnen und bestandsrentner ist
nichts rausgekommen und das holen wir
jetzt hier als ampel koalition nach
und
natürlich kann man jetzt sagen das ist
noch nicht genug die verbesserungen die
damals die neue rentner zutritts rentner
bekommen haben die müssten dann noch
etwas höher sein dafür haben wir ja ein
parlamentarisches verfahren
da können wir dann darüber diskutieren
und ich bin auch der auffassung dass wir
hier nochmal etwas verbessern sollten
und das
ist nicht nur geboten sozusagen aus
sozialer verantwortung
sondern diese stärkung einer elementaren
absicherung in unserem sozialsystem hat
auch etwas mit stabilisierung der
wirtschaft zu tun und da geht man zurück
zu den anfängen der rentenversicherung
ins jahr
1889 da ist als erster baustein die
sogenannte invalidenrente also die
heutige erwerbsminderungsrente
eingeführt worden und zwar nicht als
gnadenakt gegenüber beschäftigten
sondern weil es eine voraussetzung für
das abhängigen beschäftigungsverhältnis
für die durchsetzung des modernen
kapitalismus war
1889 mein wahlkreis ist im ruhrgebiet
entstand dieses große industriegebiet
die arbeitskräfte mussten aus masuren
dem heutigen polen angeworben werden und
welche veranlassung hätten diese gehabt
fern ihrer familie und jeder absicherung
in dieses dunkle loch zu steigen wo
einem jederzeit ein schwerer kohle
brocken oder einstein das bein
zertrümmern konnte welche veranlassung
hätten burschen vom lande gehabt in
stahlwerke zu gehen mit offenen bändern
wo er schnell der arm abgerissen werden
konnte die haben das unter anderem auch
nur deswegen gemacht und die arbeitgeber
und die industriellen mussten da auch
was anbieten weil es eine absicherung
dafür diesen fall der damals gar nicht
so unwahrscheinlich war insofern ist
soziale sicherung jetzt nicht
irgendetwas was man sich mal auch
leisten oder finanzieren muss sondern es
ist die kehrseite der wirtschaftlichen
verwertung der menschlichen arbeitskraft
ich will sich auf diesen grundsätzlichen
zusammenhang war aufmerksam machen
weil mich diesen debatten fall mich in
diesen debatten um sozialpolitik häufig
stört das dann lohnnebenkosten als
belastung gesehen werden und als bürde
und das muss man doch erstmal
erwirtschaften hindernis der wirtschaft
nein nein nein es ist so dass beides
zusammengehört und beides voraussetzung
dafür ist dass unsere volkswirtschaft
funktioniert
und im übrigen
wird das auch gespiegelt wenn uns
delegationen aus sogenannten
schwellenländern oder schon nicht mehr
nur schwellenländern industrieländern
uns besuchen es ist ja auch häufiger mal
der fall dass aus china indonesien kann
ich mich erinnern anderen ländern auch
parlamentarier kommen um hier sich
anzugucken wie läuft unser sozialsystem
und das was sie einhellig sagen ist für
unsere weitere wirtschaftliche
entwicklung
brauchen wir eine sozialversicherung und
zwar aus volkswirtschaftlichen gründen
denn was tun leute beispielsweise in
china die sich sozusagen so in den
mittelstandsbereich er hoch gearbeitet
haben was tun die wenn es keine
krankenversicherung keine
rentenversicherung gibt sie sparen sie
sparen wie die irren und darum ist die
sparquote in china riesen hoch es gibt
diesen grauen kapitalmarkt es gibt halbe
millionen städte mit leer stehenden
wohnungen die die leute besitzen als
altersvorsorge es gibt also schwerste
volkswirtschaftliche unwuchten und ein
nicht vorhandenes sozialsystem ist ein
wirtschaftliches hemmnis da wird ein
schuh draus und das finde ich sollten
auch gerade diejenigen die von der
arbeitgeberseite und die die meinen sie
politisch repräsentieren zu können das
sollten sie doch mal sich gegenwärtigen
dass wir hier zu einem positiven
volkswirtschaftlichen ansatz kommen und
die ampel wird in diesem sinne in diesem
bewusstsein und dieser verantwortung
jetzt diese erwerbsminderungsrente
weiterentwickeln und auch noch eine
menge weitere renten paket auf den weg
vielen dank
markus kurth waren das für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen in dieser debatte
in dieser ersten debatte zur
rentenanpassung 20 22 es soll ja mehr
geld geben für 21 millionen rentnerinnen
und rentner in deutschland dazu jetzt
ulrike schilke ziesing aus der
fdp-fraktion
werte bürger mit dem heute die
debattierenden gesetzesentwurf arbeitet
minister heil eine liste ab die erste
aufgaben aus dem koalitionsvertrag
enthält außerdem die jährliche
rentenanpassung
es soll eine rentenanpassung von 53
prozent west beziehungsweise
6,12 prozent ost beschlossen werden so
kann schon die frage aufkommen ist
angesichts einer derartigen
wirtschaftlichen krise in der wir uns im
moment befinden eine rentenerhöhung in
diesem umfang angemessen ich sage ja
weil die renten in deutschland ohnehin
viel zu niedrig sind und weil die
rentner von der galoppierenden inflation
der lebenshaltungskosten genauso und zum
teil sogar stärker betroffen sind als
andere
die als achte halten es deshalb für
einen fehler dass die rentner nicht in
das entlastungspaket der bundesregierung
mit einbezogen werden minister heil und
da habe ich eben eine andere auffassung
als sie in meinem heimatland mecklenburg
vorpommern leben die menschen mit den
niedrigsten renten bundesweit wer auf
grundsicherung im alter angewiesen ist
bekommt immerhin eine 200 euro
einmalzahlung auch das reicht nicht lang
aber die mehrheit die ganz knapp über
dieser grenze liegt die geht leer aus
das ist nicht in ordnung und nicht
gerecht
ich rate deshalb dringend dazu das noch
einmal zu überdenken um diese
gerechtigkeitslücke zu schließen worüber
ich mich heute freue die geplanten
verbesserungen im bereich der
erwerbsminderungsrente dieses mal
endlich für die bestandsrentner rund 15
prozent aller erwerbsminderungsrentner
sind gleichzeitig auf grundsicherung
angewiesen keine gruppe hat ein größeres
armutsrisiko
kein wunder nach dem kahlschlag von 2001
um mehr als 10 prozent sanken die
erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente jahr für jahr
weiter ins bodenlose deshalb war es auch
zu keinem zeitpunkt zu verstehen dass
die notwendigen korrekturen von 2014 und
2018 jeweils nur für die neuzugänge aber
eben nicht für die bestandsrentner
beschlossen wurden wir als fdp haben das
immer bemängelt und dass das nun behoben
werden soll ist aus unserer sicht ein
längst überfälliger schritt allerdings
ein schritt auf den rentner noch bis
juli 2024 warten müssen man könnte jetzt
auf die idee kommen dass hier politik
nach kassenlage betrieben wird es wäre
ja nicht das erste mal nur so erklärt
sich zum beispiel die benachteiligung
der mütter deren kinder vor 1992 geboren
sind nur so erklärt sich die
unterschiedliche behandlung von
betriebsrenten was die doppel vorbei
tragung betrifft nur so erklärt sich
dass es den härtefallfonds für die in
der ddr geschiedenen frauen immer noch
nicht gibt oder für die berufsgruppen
die bei der rentenüberleitung durchs
rost gefallen sind das heißt so oft
setzt sich die politik erst in bewegung
wenn sie muss das ergebnis ist ein wust
an regelungen die niemand mehr geschaut
und die unter gerechtigkeit aspekten
äußerst fragwürdig sind ich weiß nicht
ob es ein trost ist wenigstens die
stichtagsregelung für die einführung der
zuschläge für die erwerbsminderungsrente
lässt sich ein sachlich erklären denn
die nächsten zwei jahre stehen bei der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung komplett
im zeichen dass werden über leitungs
abschluss gesetzes und der grundrente
für mehr gibt es weder technische noch
personelle kapazitäten liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wenn eine ganze behörde auf
jahre blockiert ist so das neue gesetz
sozusagen in warteschleife produziert
werden müssen dann läuft etwas falsch
entweder bei der gesetzgebung oder bei
der ausstattung der behörde auch hier
ist die regierung gefordert anspruch und
wirklichkeit zu überprüfen und
entsprechend zu handeln
im falle der erwerbsminderungsrentner
die noch so lange auf unterstützung
warten müssen könnte das so aussehen
dass sie eine komplette nachzahlung der
zuschläge für das verlorene jahr erfolgt
darüber diskutiere ich gerne mit ihnen
im ausschuss für arbeit und soziales wie
als afd werden uns einer
leistungsverbesserung studenten er
jedenfalls nicht verweigern und auch
einen entsprechenden gesetzesentwurf
unterstützen vielen dank
[Applaus]
ulrike ziesing für und aus der afg
fraktion in der debatte über die
rentenanpassung 20
22 und in dieser debatte wird die
nächste rednerin sein anja schulz aus
der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich halte
den vorliegenden gesetzesentwurf für
einen erfolg damit seinen drei
hauptelemente der erhöhung der renten
der reaktivierung des nachwuchses und
der verbesserung der
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand kann
man ihn vor einem einzelnen fair
gegenüber den rentnerinnen und rentnern
die uns durch ihre arbeit in den letzten
jahrzehnten dahin gebracht haben wo
heute wirtschaftlich stehen fair
gegenüber den erwerbsminderung es
denjenigen über erwerbsminderungsrente
beziehen denn unsere solidarische
gesellschaft steht für jene ein die aus
eigener kraft ihren beitrag nicht mehr
voll oder nur noch teilweise leisten
können und fair auch gegenüber den
kommenden generationen dennoch ihre
belange werden mit deren
anpassungsformel wieder besser
berücksichtigt
die reaktivierung des nachhol praxis
führt dazu dass rentenpolitik nicht nur
für heutige rentner gemacht wird sondern
auch für deren enkelkinder was die ltg
nation besser stellt darf der jüngeren
später nicht auf die füße fallen und wer
jetzt behauptet dass aktuell nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt dafür seien um davon
gebrauch zu machen der hat nicht
verstanden dass man
generationengerechtigkeit nicht einfach
aussetzen kann
es kann nämlich nicht sein dass wir uns
mit dem thema erst beschäftigen wenn es
uns in den kram passt probleme die man
vor sich hin schiebt das denen jetzt
gerade an anderen stellen die fliegen
einen irgendwann um die ohren
maßnahmen wie diese haben aber auch viel
mit aufklärungsarbeit zu tun ich musste
einige artikel und meinungen lesen in
dem der nachholfaktor als eine art
diebstahl an den heutigen rentnerinnen
und rentnern dargestellt wird eine
maßnahme über die so informiert wird
kann willkommen auf verständnis stoßen
ich mache die wirkung einmal deutlich
die renten steigen mit den löhnen sie
fallen aber nicht mit ihnen dafür sorgt
die rentengarantie und ist auch gut so
diese ausgeblieben gekürzt so muss
allerdings irgendwann mal wieder
nachgeholt werden damit die renten den
löhnen nicht davonlaufen so weit so
logisch der nachholfaktor ist also ein
nachhaltiger beitrag für die
finanzierbarkeit unseres systems
die vorherige aussetzung war eine
ungerechte manipulation der
rentenanpassungsformel zulasten der
jüngeren generation
solche ungerechtigkeiten sollten wir aus
der welt schaffen und wir müssen endlich
aufhören die debatten um den willen ist
allen recht zu machen immer auf dem
rücken der jungen generation
auszufechten
denn trotz der einführung des
nachholfaktor können sich die 21
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner in
unserem land auch ein poppiges
rentenplus freuen im westen ist es sogar
das größte in den letzten 40 jahren
jetzt wohl mit blick auf den
kassenzettel auffällt dass wir in
schwierigen zeiten nehmen ist diese
erhöhung auch besonders notwendig
doch notwendigkeiten gibt es in der
rentenpolitik sehr viele ein problem das
steht schon sehr lange im raum dass
durch viele ansätze bisher noch nicht
geklärt werden konnte die geplante
verbesserung der erwerbsminderungsrente
bestand ist eine enorme erleichterung
für eine gruppe die in unserer
gesellschaft leider nur eine sehr
geringe lobby hat sie erhält pauschalen
zuschlag wir freuen uns dass es für alle
ampel tat eine selbstverständlichkeit
war diese vernachlässigung endlich
anzugehen damit stellen wir drei
millionen
erwerbsminderungsrente rinnen und
rentner und auch jene die inzwischen in
altersrente sind in der zukunft besser
und zukunft dass es auch ein wichtiges
stichwort mit dem ich schließen möchte
zukunft für unsere rentenversicherung
ist an viele stabilisierenden maßnahmen
geknüpft der nachholfaktor leistet dabei
einen beitrag
es muss aber noch mehr kommen die
kapitaldeckung ist dafür das beste
konzept seit langem unsere demokratie
arbeitet gegen unser rentensystem
also müssen wir uns schritt für schritt
unabhängiger von ihr machen lassen wir
die zukünftigen rentnerinnen und rentner
am produktivkapital teilhaben und zeigen
wir auch der jungen generation dass sie
sich auf unser rentensystem auch in
zukunft verlassen kann
anja schulz für die fdp fraktion und
damit auch für die
koalitionsfraktionen zur rentenanpassung
2022 die altersbezüge sollen steigen zum
ersten juli um 53 5 prozent im osten auf
6,12 prozent nächster redner dazu ist
matthias birkwald rentenpolitischer
sprecher der linksfraktion
sprechen sie den menschen die wegen
einer chronischen krankheit zwischen
2001 und 2008 10 in eine
erwerbsminderungsrente gehen mussten
ihre renten zu verbessern das ist gut
das haben wir linken seit langem
gefordert für uns linke ist klar
krankheit darf nicht arm machen dafür
sind ihre zuschläge von 75 und 4,5
prozent mehr
erwerbsminderungsrente aber viel zu
niedrig bei einer durchschnittlichen
rente von aktuell nur
886 euro während das zwar immerhin gut
66 bzw fast 40 euro mehr netto im monat
aber diesen zuschlag wollen sie
frühestens in zwei jahren ab dem ersten
juli 20 24 auszahlen dass meine damen
und herren es ist völlig inakzeptabel
die betroffenen müssen seit 2014
ertragen dass ihre von viel zu hohen
abschlägen und viel zu kurzen
zurechnungszeiten betroffenen
armutsrenten nicht verbessert wurden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
koalition lieber hubertus heil sie
möchten die viel zu lange vergessenen
menschen nun ein weiteres mal mehr als
zwei jahre im regen stehen lassen dazu
sage ich ihnen das geht gar nicht
ich habe ja verständnis für die probleme
der rentenversicherung aber wenn es
wirklich nicht schneller gehen sollte
dann müssen den betroffenen im jahr 2024
wenigstens die zuschläge für die
verlorenen zwei jahre rückwirkend
erstattet werden das fordert der
deutsche gewerkschaftsbund das fordern
alle sozialverbände das fordern wir
linken und darum werden wir dazu einen
entsprechenden änderungsantrag
einbringen aber damit nicht genug sie
erwecken den eindruck mit den zuschlägen
würden sie diejenigen die zwischen 2001
und 2008 10 in eine
erwerbsminderungsrente
gegangen sind mit jenen gleichstellen
die seit 2009 10 von den besseren
zurechnungszeiten profitieren dieser
eindruck ist falsch
für eine echte gleichstellung müssten
die zuschläge fast auf acht und auf 13
prozent verdoppelt werden das hat ihnen
der sozialverband deutschland präzise
vorgerechnet aber in ihrem gesetzentwurf
heißt es dass es den zuschlag nur bis zu
einem zitat finanzvolumen von 2,6
milliarden euro zitat ende geben soll ja
wo haben sie denn diese zahl her mir
scheint die wurde von finanzminister
lindner ausgewürfelt denn diese zahl ist
völlig willkürlich und vor allem sie ist
viel zu niedrig
sie wollen
zehn milliarden euro für eine obskure
aktien rente ausgeben aber chronisch
kranken abends rentnerinnen und rentnern
knapp die hälfte des notwendigen
zuschlages verweigern wir wollen sie
dennoch bei den ärmsten rentner gruppen
einsparen nein das ist das gegenteil von
sozialer gerechtigkeit und das ist nur
noch zum kopfschütteln auch deshalb
werden wir einen durchgerechneten
änderungsantrag einbringen und auch für
diesen wird die linke als stimme der
sozialen gerechtigkeit die unterstützung
der sozialverbände erhalten dessen bin
ich mir sicher verehrte bundesregierung
auf druck der fdp führen sie den zurecht
ausgesetzten nachholfaktor wieder ein
damit kürzen sie die diesjährige im
vergleich zwar sehr hohe rentenerhöhung
aber angesichts einer inflation von bis
zu sieben prozent viel zu niedrige
renten erhöhung um 0,6 prozentpunkte und
das ist schlecht
lieber robert detail dass sich die
rentnerinnen und rentner im juli über
mindestens 5,35 prozent mehr rente
freuen dürfen ist bei diesem gegenwind
der fdp wirklich eine große leistung
chapeau aber nach ihrem gesetzentwurf
die rentenanpassung 20 23 in der heißen
inflationsphase von ursprünglich 5,4 auf
2,9 prozent gekürzt werden und damit die
kaufkraft der renten inmitten einer
energiepreis krise auch im kommenden
jahr entwerten das darf nicht passieren
und deshalb sage ich die aktuell
ausgezahlte durchschnittsrente aller
21,2 millionen rentnerinnen und rentner
liegt nur bei 1089 euro vor steuern das
heißt die rentnerinnen und rentner
brauchen jeden cent die rente muss zum
leben reichen bessern sie diesen
gesetzentwurf nach herzlichen dank
fordert der rentenpolitische sprecher
der linksfraktion matthias birkwald
und wir werden hören was dazu sagt
michael gerdes aus der spd fraktion
auch präsidentin meine damen und herren
dass das gesetzesvorhaben dass wir heute
beraten wird von vielen menschen seit
langem herbeigesehnt
auch von mir und wir beschließen mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzesentwurf nicht nur
die rentenanpassung sondern auch
verbesserungen für sogenannte
rentnerinnen und rentner im
erwerbsminderungsrente bestand also von
menschen die von anfang 2001 bis 2008
zehn erwerbsminderungsrente bezogen
haben oder in erwerbsminderungsrente
gegangen sind und die bislang wenig von
den verbesserungen aus den jahren 2014
und 2019 gespürt haben sie sind zum teil
mit erheblichen abschlägen in rente
gegangen und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir neben den verbesserungen die
wir für die neue renten orientieren
gemacht haben jetzt auch an die
bestandsrentner herangehen und den auch
etwas zukommen lassen wir korrigieren
jetzt ein gerechtigkeitslücke die uns
seit jahren
um die für viele betroffene nicht
nachvollziehbar war und es bis heute
nicht ist liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
erwerbsminderungsrenten werden nicht
freiwillig in anspruch genommen sie
werden dann beantragt wenn jemand wegen
einer krankheit oder eines unfalls
ausscheidet und das vorzeitige aus
seinem berufsleben und nur unter großen
einschränkungen weiter arbeiten kann und
genau diese menschen brauchen unseren
besonderen schutz und unsere solidarität
die solidarität der
versicherungsgemeinschaft
insofern sind die geplante zuschläge
mehr als berechtigt und es ist auch
berechtigt das ebenso menschen mit
alters- und hinterbliebenenrente diese
zuschläge erhalten wenn sie eine
erwerbsminderungsrente im dafür
vorgesehenen zeitraum bezogen haben und
die erhöhung für knapp drei millionen
menschen über die wir heute reden ist
eine vereinbarung aus dem
koalitionsvertrag
und ist richtig dass wir dieses vorhaben
zügig als eines der ersten umsätzen
allerdings das muss ich auch sagen gibt
es noch einige wermutstropfen dabei etwa
die auszahlung des zuschlags erst zum
ersten juli 2014 das trübt die freude
und schmerz nicht persönlich auch das
kann ich ihnen versichern aber
die umsetzung muss auch machbar sein und
von der rentenversicherung zuverlässig
und fehlerfrei nach getesteten verfahren
realisiert werden können sowohl wenn es
um das verfahren einzelner bearbeitungen
geht als auch um die programmierung von
daten
nichtsdestotrotz werde ich mich die spd
sich dafür einsetzen dass wir den späten
beginn noch einmal überdenken und einen
ausgleich finden das werden wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren sicherlich
noch diskutieren einen anderen punkt
dagegen kann nicht vorbehaltlos
unterstützen und das meine damen und
herren ist die automatische auszahlung
wir wollen den teilweise betagten
betroffene keine komplizierten
antragsverfahren mehr zumuten und dabei
profitieren wir aktuell von den guten
erfahrungen bei der grundrente mein
herzlicher dank geht an dieser stelle an
das bundesarbeitsministerium und diesen
dank finde ich muss man auch mal
aussprechen
auch anträge zu verzichten ist nicht nur
eine frage des respekts vor den menschen
es ist auch ein schutz vor zu viel
bürokratie und vor allem ist es sozial
gerecht denn wir wissen wir nicht wir
können alle in die situation einer
erwerbsminderungsrente wir sprechen
heute jedoch nicht nur über die
verbesserung für
erwerbsminderungsrentner rinnen und
rentner sondern auch über ein üppiges
rentenplus ab juli dieses jahres und
meine damen und herren wir stehen vor
einer ungewöhnlich hohen
rentenanpassungen der höchsten seit fast
40 jahren und das ist schon etwas 5 35
prozent erhöhung in westdeutschland und
6 12 prozent in den neuen bundesländern
oft gesagt hier aber immer wieder gerne
noch mal betont das ist im übrigen auch
mehr als ein einmaliger zuschuss bei der
energie beihilfe und ende november kurz
nach koalitionsverhandlungen lieber herr
bundesminister hubertus heil haben sie
selbst noch nichtmals gewagt von solchen
zahlen zu sprechen umso höher müssen wir
jetzt die kräftige anhebung der renten
für 21 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentner einschätzen zumal in einer zeit
in der diese erhöhung angesichts von
inflation und internationalen krisen
dringend gebraucht wird und dabei
berüchtigten wir auf den faktor der die
höhe der rente zwar dämpft aber für
einen ausgleich zwischen löhnen und
renten sorgt und die renten folgen den
löhnen das haben wir auch schon gehört
und dieses prinzip haben wir 20 21 von
aufgrund von corona nicht eingehalten
und trotz des pandemie bedingten
einbruchs der einnahmen ich erinnere in
diesem zusammenhang an die kurzarbeit
übrigens ein gutes instrument haben wir
im letzten jahr keine renten zum
durchgeführt und dafür hat die
rentengarantie gesorgt eine garantie die
sich für viele rednerinnen rennt noch
als wichtiger anker erwiesen hat die
rentengarantie war in der korona krise
das richtige signal
das rennen land kostet in der werks
bildungs renten bestands verbesserungs
gesetz werde ich ein wort ist jetzt
weitere verbesserung vorausgesetzt das
richtige signal besser meine damen und
herren wäre es aber wenn es gar nicht
erst dazu käme dass menschen
erwerbsminderungsrente beziehen durch
mehr und bessere
rehabilitation können menschen länger
gesund am arbeitsmarkt bleiben und
lassen sie uns auch daran arbeiten
herzlichen dank
michael gerdes aus und für die spd
fraktion zur rentenanpassung
2022 die stärkste rentenerhöhung seit
1994 betonte die bundesregierung und ein
zusätzlicher zuschlag für drei millionen
bezieher von erwerbsminderungsrenten
nächster redner kai wetterchaos der
unionsfraktion
festhalten dass wir als union uns immer
die erhöhung der renten ausdrücklich
freuen wir freuen uns deshalb darüber
weil es zeigt dass wir letztes jahr eine
gute wirtschaftliche entwicklung haben
und dafür war auch die union
verantworten und herr kurt ich wunder
mich da schon dass sie zweifel haben
konnten dass wir jetzt einen nicht auf
dem sozialpolitischen kurs bleiben ich
kann ihnen nur sagen wer hat's erfunden
das waren wir mit der sozialen
marktwirtschaft und
wir freuen uns auch über die
verbesserungen bei der
erwerbsminderungsrente nen auch dafür
haben wir lange gekämpft und herr
minister wir hätten uns auch schon sehr
gefreut wenn es in der letzten
legislaturperiode dazu einen vorschlag
vorgelegt hätten wir haben das immer
gefordert und sie hätten
und ich glaube mit uns hätten sich 20
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner heute
noch mehr gefordert gefreut wenn sie ein
zusätzliches entlastungspaket für die
rentnerinnen und rentner präsentiert
hätten denn es ist nicht verständlich
warum jemand der gutes geld verdient in
diesem land 300 euro zusätzliches
energie geld bekommt während der
durchschnittsrentner mit 1300 euro rente
leer ausgeht das ist die ungerechtigkeit
ist sie hier machen
es soll noch mal der blick auf die
details ich habe eben gesagt die
erwerbsminderungsrente wird verbessert
7,5 und 45 prozent zuschlag aber da gebe
ich dem kollegen birkwald recht die
zahlen sind nicht wirklich hergeleitet
und dann hatte ich auch erst in verdacht
dass es vielleicht an christian lindner
im finanzministerium liegen könnte und
dann ist mir aber beim zweiten blick
aufgefallen dass es ja gar nicht der
steuerzahler durch einen zusätzlichen
zuschuss bezahlt sondern dass sie den
beitragszahler belasten ohne es ihm zu
sagen und da herr kurth da wundere ich
mich schon denn in den letzten acht
jahren haben sie von diesem platz aus
uns immer vorgeworfen wenn die
beitragszahlungen und beitragszahler für
renten verbesserungen aufkommen mussten
nicht der steuerzahler sieht machen es
jetzt genauso herzlich willkommen im
club erfurt
und die lage ist wirklich schlimm denn
sie werden in den nächsten vier jahren
die rücklage der rentenversicherung
komplett plündern fast 40 milliarden
sind jetzt in der rücklage das haben wir
in 16 jahren aufgebaut sorgsam zu
verplempern diese rücklage binnen vier
jahren das ist ihre politik von namen
und es kommt noch schlimmer sie plündern
nicht nur die rücklage sondern sie
kürzen sogar noch den steuerzuschuss um
eine halbe milliarde euro pro jahr auch
da
klauen sie quasi den rentnerinnen und
rentnern das geld in den nächsten vier
jahren und dann kommen sie mit dem
nachholfaktor fans das ist das liberale
freiburg wo sie hielt sich rühmen die
für die generationengerechtigkeit etwas
getan zu haben es bewirkt dass es ein
prozent weniger rentenerhöhungen gibt
das sind vier milliarden euro weniger
aber es greift nur für ein ja und dann
ist das ding ein papiertiger warum weil
sie gleichzeitig das rentenniveau auf 48
prozent festlegen und zwar für die
nächsten vier jahre und diesem wert den
erreichen sie schon ab dem jahr 2023 das
heißt dann wird ihr nachholfaktor
einfach ausgesetzt und insofern
schreiben sie eine rentenreform fest aus
der renten kommission wurde ja
verschieden des diskutiert den letzten
vier jahren ohne aber über die anderen
dinge erkennen eintrittsalter
beitragshöhen et cetera steuerzuschuss
zu diskutieren da haben sie sich teuer
etwas einkauf und der fdp was nichts
nutzt das es wirklich eine versagte
politik und
und auf das eigentliche reformprojekt
des jahres ja schon fast des
jahrhunderts warten na ja alle ganz
gespannt nämlich auf die aktien rente
dazu haben sie heute alle irgendwie
nichts gesagt es scheint ja so dass
das phantom des deutschen bundestages zu
sein
ich bin sehr gespannt ob sie das noch
bringen werden aber auch hier habe ich
das gefühl sie haben etwas bestellt und
es ist noch längst nicht ausgeliefert
worden wir werden ihn dabei sein auf die
finger gucken und sind sehr gespannt wie
die beratungen in diesem gesetz
weitergehen dankeschön
kritiker aus der unionsfraktion wartet
auf das stichwort aktion hätte da muss
er wahrscheinlich noch ein klein wenig
warten aber johannes vogel aus der
fdp-fraktion der wird hier gleich auch
noch das wort der gleichen und dann
nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich dass er sich
dazu äußert jetzt aber erstmal frank
bsirske der arbeitsmarkt- und
sozialpolitischer sprecher der grünen
ist und von 2001 bis 19 verdi
vorsitzender war
der hörte damen und herren von der union
an ihnen wirklich beeindruckt heute ist
ein erstaunliches maß an unbekümmertheit
und selbstvergessenheit
sie stehen für alle retten politik die
darauf hinausläuft gelaufen wäre wenn es
nicht zu einer stabilisierung des
rentenniveaus käme
millionenfach menschen mit altersarmut
zu bedrohen weil sie in die nähe oder
auf grundsicherungsniveau gebracht
werden und damit in eine situation wo
die legitimation der rentenversicherung
massiv bedroht ist wenn man trotzdem
zehnte langer beitragszahlung und arbeit
nicht meiner rente rechnen kann von der
man an ständen über die runden kommt und
in würde alt werden dann wir stehen für
eine andere politik für eine politik die
dafür sorgt dass nach jahrzehntelanger
beitragszahlung eine rente erfolgt die
dazu reicht an ständen über die runden
zu kommen und in würde alt werden zu
können das unterscheidet uns
grundsätzlich
möchte im vorliegenden report
nehmen sich die ampel einer der am
meisten armutsgefährdeten gruppen
unserer bevölkerung an am besten sie
denken um einen wo ein ihre eigene
politik der nächsten jahre da gibt es
wirklich viel anders so
mit dem
vorliegenden entwurf
nimmt sich die ampel einer der am
meisten armutsgefährdeten gruppen
unserer bevölkerung an drei millionen
menschen mit häufig prekäre
einkommenssituation
die weit überdurchschnittlich angewiesen
sind auf grundsicherungs bezug
die benachteiligung der
erwerbsminderungsrente rinnen und
rentner im bestand zu beenden war teil
des grünen wahlprogramms das jetzt nicht
nur aktive erwacht minderungsrecht
gerinnen und rentner sondern auch daran
anschließende altersrenten da fast
werden ist angemessen und
verhindert einen erneuten teilausschluss
betroffener so wie sie ihn über jahre
praktiziert haben was jetzt vorliegt
was jetzt vorliegt bringt eine
verbesserung von durchschnittlich 50
euro im monat und ist lange überfällig
wir wurden ist freilich begrüßen
wenn ich versorgungslücke der bestands
rentnerinnen und rentner hat zudem die
nach 2018 9 zu kommen nicht nur wie im
gesetzentwurf vorgesehen zur hälfte
sondern vollständig geschlossen würden
da waren arbeiten wir zurzeit macht und
ich hoffe sehr dass es uns in der ampel
gelingen wird unsere sozialen
verantwortung so gerecht zu werden wie
dies geboten ist
und ein wermutstropfen ist auch der
zeitpunkt zu dem die verbesserung in
kraft treten soll der erste siebte 2024
das ist in mehr als zwei jahren
der späte zeitpunkt ist operativen
problem weil der deutschen
rentenversicherung geschuldet die die
umsetzung technisch nicht früher welt
sichtbar machen
freilich freilich
freilich könnten wir dafür sorgen dass
dies nicht frontal zu lasten der
betroffenen geht in dem zuschläge rück
wirklich geleistet werden etwa mit
wirkung ab wir im ersten ersten und 24
das würde zur
2026 betone 2026
eine beitragssteigerung um 0,1 prozent
notwendig machen und einen um quatschen
und streckt dazwischen
und einen um 400 millionen höheren
bundeszuschuss
was aber sehr überschaubare bliebe
jedoch für drei millionen menschen eine
wichtige verbesserung bedeuten würde und
zugleich ein ende der benachteiligung
daran wie es noch zu ermöglichen
arbeiten hier ich finde wir sind es
diesen weit überproportional von armut
betroffenen menschen unschuldig
frank bsirske für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen zum thema rentenanpassung
2022 das ist ja eines der felder wo die
koalition spd grüne fdp am meisten
gesprächsbedarf auch untereinander haben
nächste rednerin ist gerät hui aus der
fdp-fraktion frühere daimler-manager in
und maßgeblich beteiligt am
rentenkonzept der afg
rentenerhöhung seit 40 jahren und auch
die medien sind begeistert und obwohl
wir diesem gesetz grundsätzlich positiv
gegenüber stehen können wir in diesem
jubel nicht mit einstimmen denn die
rentner haben in den letzten drei
jahrzehnten einen kaufkraftverlust von
über 30 prozent erlitten
von einem leben in würde können viele
von ihnen nur noch träumen
und auch die jetzige rentenanpassung
obwohl nominell hoch kann die
expandierende inflation die grünen
sprechen von sieben bis acht mal höheren
gaspreisen nicht kompensieren ein
weiterer kaufkraftverlust wird die folge
sein wir haben das daher sehr bedauert
dass die regierung in ihren entlastungs
paketen die rentner vergessen hat 300
euro als inflations kompensation hätten
doch noch drin sein müssen
aber der regierung für anderes wichtiger
wir werden daher in kürze einen eigenen
antrag vorlegen in dem wir sie auf
worten diese 300 euro für unsere rentner
noch nachzulegen es ist traurig aber
wahr die deutschen rentner schneiden im
europäischen vergleich sehr schlecht ab
franzose bekommen im schnitt 60 prozent
mehr rente österreicher 80 prozent mehr
niederländer doppelt so viel wie wir und
die schweizer mehr als viermal so viel
und die zahl jener die von uns über den
coup wiederaufbau also in eu next
generation 40 milliarden teure man
ebenso geschenkt bekommen haben erhalten
60 prozent mehr rente als wir und müssen
dafür sieben jahre weniger arbeiten und
da sie auch noch einige jahre länger
leben als wir können sie ihre renten
insgesamt auch einige jahre länger
beziehen
nach eur statt sind mittlerweile fast 30
prozent aller über 65 jährigen in
unserem land armutsgefährdet tendenz
steigend dann laut einer auskunft der
bundesregierung von vor zwei jahren
verdienen 15 millionen beschäftigte
nicht genug um im alter eine rente zu
erhalten die über der grundsicherung
liegt
grundsicherung das ist sozialhilfe und
die bekommt auch jeder andere egal ob
gearbeitet hat oder nicht
meine damen und herren dass unsere
rentner wirklich brauchen sind nicht
finanzielle trostpflaster
die immer der entwicklung
hinterherhinken sondern eine
grundlegende rentenreform die diesen
namen auch wirklich verdient
damit wieder gerade gerückt wird was in
den letzten drei jahrzehnten kaputt
gemacht worden ist andernfalls wird
unser land zum armenhaus der alten und
damit das nicht passiert braucht es an
den ganzen strauß von maßnahmen eine der
wichtigsten ist es den niedriglohnsektor
überflüssig zu machen in diesem punkt
stimmen wir mit unseren kollegen von der
spd durchaus überein
denn voraussetzung für gute renten sind
gute löhne dabei muss allerdings
augenmaß bewahrt werden damit unsere
wirtschaft des überhaupt bewältigen kann
die ja gerade durch die sanktionspolitik
der ampel vor nahezu unlösbare
aufgaben gestellt wird
und natürlich sind voraussetzung gute
löhne bestens ausgebildete arbeitskräfte
denn der internationale wettbewerb
erlaubt uns gute löhne nur bei
entsprechend guten leistungen das heißt
wir brauchen wieder schulen die auch
funktionieren aber das meine damen und
herren wird nun möglich werden wenn die
regieren dann endlich ihre ideologischen
scheuklappen ablegen
geräte die aus der eifel die fraktion
die heute übrigens geburtstag hat
nächste rednerin in der debatte zur
rentenanpassung die 20 22 willi klein
aus der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die erwerbsminderungsrente ist eine
wichtige soziale absicherung denn wer
sie bezieht kann meist aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht mehr
arbeiten
krankheit darf kein schicksal sein und
lieber herr kollege kurz das ist weder
links noch rechts das ist das fundament
unserer sozialen marktwirtschaft
und genau deshalb begrüßen wir auch die
vorgesehene erweiterung der
erwerbsminderungsrente die anknüpft an
die regelung die wir als unionsgeführte
bundesregierung in den letzten jahren
bereits für neuzugänge geschaffen haben
besser wäre natürlich gewesen sie käme
bereits nächstes jahr und nicht erst
2024 die kritik dazu kommt ja sogar aus
ihren eigenen reihen
auch die wiedereinführung des
nachholfaktor es ist zu begrüßen denn er
ist ein wichtiger beitrag zur
generationengerechtigkeit
nicht im sinne der nachhaltigkeit ist
allerdings die streichung der 500
millionen euro aus dem haushalt eine
sonderzuweisung des bundes die explizit
zur sicherung des rentenniveaus
vorgesehen war
für viele rentnerinnen und rentner sind
die steigerungen im westen um 5,3
prozent und im osten um 6,1 prozent eine
entlastung zur wahrheit gehört aber auch
dass diese rentensteigerung im alltag
der rentnerinnen und rentner kaum
spürbar sein wird sie gleich noch nicht
einmal die preissteigerung beim einkauf
im supermarkt aus das klang hier
vermehrt anhält und hinzu kommt dass
bisher sämtliche entlastungsmaßnahmen
der us-regierung für bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen an den rentnerinnen
und rentnern vorbeigehen wir kritisieren
dass ausdrücklich denn der es mit der
bekämpfung von altersarmut ernst meint
er weil er spart nicht bei den
bedürftigen rentnern
keine frage im gesetzentwurf finden sich
richtige ansätze am ende des tages sind
es aber
einzelmaßnahmen bei denen in die
richtige richtung gezielt aber nicht
weit genug geworfen wird was fehlt ist
eine grundlegende vorstellung davon wie
altersvorsorge
zukunftsfest gemacht werden kann der
wille zur strukturellen reformen ist
hier nicht erkennbar in den kommenden
jahren werden die baby boomer in rente
gehen laut studien dürfte der zenit der
beschäftigten und damit der
beitragszahler mit 46 millionen im
kommenden jahr erreicht werden man muss
kein mathe genie sein um festzustellen
dass bei gleich bleibend niedriger
geburtenrate perspektivisch immer
weniger junge menschen immer mehr
rentnern gegenüberstehen werden und im
sinne der generationengerechtigkeit
braucht das deshalb ein
zukunftsgerichteten ansatz der alle drei
säulen der altersvorsorge
stärkt
die idee einer kapitalgedeckten
altersvorsorge wäre ein guter erster
schritt gewesen ich kann mich erinnern
dass die liberalen davon mal ganz große
fans waren hier konnte sich aber die
ampel noch nicht einmal dazu durch den
zehn milliarden euro im haushalt
einzuplanen ein betrag mit dem ein
öffentlicher renten fonds kaum effizient
arbeiten könnte ich muss sagen
eigentlich ist es erschreckend zu sehen
wie wenig gestaltungswillen die ampel
für die zukunft der altersvorsorge zeigt
bleibt nur zu hoffen dass es nicht
irgendwann heißt trennte sich wer kann
vielen dank
willi klein aus der unionsfraktion und
ihr fraktionskollege kurt egger hat
vorhin schon gefragt wurde in das
stichwort 18 rente bleibt wenn es dafür
eine chance gibt dann ist es der nächste
redner ist johannes vogel aus der
fdp-fraktion rentenexperte seiner
fraktion aber auch erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
liebe
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich freue mich noch einmal
einer sozialpolitischen debatte das wort
ergreifen zu können weil ich glaube dass
das wirklich ein
wegweisendes gesetz ist was wir hier
heute auf den weg bringen und das
ist es erstmal ganz offenkundig schon
mit blick auf die zahlen sehr erfreulich
welche rentenerhöhung dadurch ausgelöst
wird für die rentnerinnen und rentner in
diesem land das ist ja keine frage von
politischer willkür sondern wir wenden
hier die rentenformel an aber es führt
dazu dass wir über fünf prozent renten
hören lassen und über sechs prozent
rentenerhöhung im osten haben werden ich
sage zwei dinge ganz klar erstens liebe
kollegen kollegen von der opposition das
ist wirklich bemerkenswert und das sieht
man schon daran dass es die höchste
rentenerhöhung seit
1983 ist das war das erste jahr eines
arbeitsministers norbert blüm das ist
wirklich historischen eine gute
nachricht für die rentner in diesem land
liebe kolleginnen vorleben und
[Applaus]
das ist keine frage für die politiker
dank verdienen weil das haben die
rentnerinnen und rentner verdient weil
rente ist keine sozialleistung sondern
ergibt sich aus deren arbeitsleistung
aber es ist trotzdem eine gute nachricht
und liebe kolleginnen kollegen von der
union max straubinger ich habe mich sehr
gefreut dass ihr den schritt mit der em
rendeler gelobt und b als überfällig
markiert habt immer in einen schritt wo
selbst matthias birkwald gesagt hat also
was das finanziell auswirkt das sei
immerhin beachtenswert meine von den
linken kommen was immer weggelassen habe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union ist das das wort die das in der
letzten legislaturperiode verhindert
haben danke dass ihr lob dass wir eure
politik verändern ziemlich richtig das
zu machen
dass das die rentenerhöhung jetzt so
ausfällt hat übrigens auch damit zu tun
dass wir umfangreich kurzarbeitergeld in
dieser krise genutzt haben das zeigt die
handlungsfähigkeit unseres sozialstaats
in der krise und das ist auch eine gute
nachricht das zeigt aber auch ja dafür
gerne applaus das zeigt aber auch wie
wichtig es ist dass wir auf solide
finanzen achten damit unser sozialstaat
unser staat in der krise unzweifelhaft
handlungsfähig ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und das
führt zur bedeutung des nachwuchses denn
das ist in der tat das erste
stabilisierungsgesetz und das erste
stabilisierung cent bei den renten
finanzen seit 15 jahren und das ist
erstens richtig mit blick auf
finanzielle stabilität und das ist
zweitens richtig mit blick auf fairness
weil es dafür sorgt dass die generation
auch in der krise zusammenhalten und
renten und löhne sich im gleichklang
entwickeln und ich will gerne darauf
eingehen was hierzu zwischenrufe aus der
union kamen eben auch in der debatte
geäußert wurden also der kollege wittek
und der kollege straubinger die haben
gesagt sie als union hätten dafür die
grundlage gelegt erstens weil die
soziale marktwirtschaft erfunden haben
also liebe kolleginnen kollegen bei
allem respekt nicht alleine sondern das
hat diese ganze haus in früheren
generationen auf den weg gebracht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vor allem
respekt gegenüber der historischen
leistung der union aber konkret beim
nachholfaktor da ist ja sogar das genaue
gegenteil richtig weil die letzte
legislaturperiode ist ja unter anderem
die union war die nicht bereit war das
thema anzugehen obwohl es offensichtlich
notwendig war es ist diese ampel
koalition die das jetzt auf den weg
bringt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist auch nicht irgendwie ein
zwischenschritt oder etwas derartiges
sondern was hier passiert ist dass die
ausgebliebene rentensenkung
richtigerweise wegen der rentengarantie
komplett in einem jahr verrechnet wird
dh in einem jahr steht diese koalition
stabilität fairness zwischen den
generationen wieder her das ist die
wahrheit liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union und wenn ich es mir nicht
glaubt kann man es ja der süddeutschen
zeitung glauben die haben nämlich am 22
märz diesen jahres bei der vorlage des
gesetzes geschrieben wenn jemand ein
beispiel für politische vernunft und
fairness sucht hier hat er das recht hat
die süddeutsche zeitung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
das heißt die wahrheit ist wir stoßen
hier die tür auch für eine effiziente
und in diesem weg werden wir auch
weitergehen mit weiteren maßnahmen in
den nächsten monaten vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
johannes vogel rentenexperte eben der
fdp fraktion
auch mal eine arbeitsagentur geleitet in
wuppertal vorübergehend zumindest und
wir sind beim vorletzten redner in
dieser aussprache stefan ecke kommt aus
der unionsfraktion und kollegen
verlässlichkeit schafft vertrauen das
gilt für alle politischen bereiche das
gilt besonders für die alterssicherung
der menschen die jahrzehntelang
gearbeitet hat muss darauf vertrauen
können von der rente leben zu können es
ist gut dass die rentnerinnen und
rentner in deutschland an der
allgemeinen wohlstandsentwicklung
teilhaben deswegen hat konrad adenauer
1957 die rentenentwicklung an die
lohnentwicklung gekoppelt
65 jahre später gilt das immer noch das
nenne ich verlässliche rentenpolitik die
vertrauen schafft
die union begrüßt daher die vom
bundesminister angekündigte
rentenerhöhung von gut 6 prozent in
ostdeutschland und gut 5% investor stand
auch den pauschalen zuschlag zu den
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand finden
wir zunächst einmal richtig
rentensteigerung von mehr als fünf
prozent das klingt auf dem papier gut
die traurige wahrheit ist aber in den
portemonnaies der rentnerinnen und
rentner kommt davon nichts an denn durch
die akute inflation werden die
rentenerhöhungen komplett geschluckt
einem plus von 5 bis 6 prozent stehen
folgende drei steigerung gegenüber
heizöl los 144 superbenzin + 42 butter
mehl pro 17 und gemüse plus 15 prozent
gerade in inflations und krisenzeiten
müssen die menschen das vertrauen haben
dass politik für sicherheit sorgt dass
sie sich verlässlich an die selbst
gesetzten regeln hält und nicht bloß
nach aktueller kassenlage entscheidend
mit den verschiedenen staatsleistungen
sofort zuschlag für kinder
einmalzahlungen und die energiepreis
pauschale versucht die ampel regierung
den preisschock für die bevölkerung
abzumildern
wer gute politik für die menschen machen
will muss diese krisen leistungen im
zusammenhang mit unseren heutigen
unserer heutigen rentendebatte sehen sie
schließen die rentnerinnen und rentner
ganz bewusst von diesen leistungen aus
sie lassen sie im regen stehen von den
sozialverbänden haben die dafür am
montag in der sachverständigenanhörung
zu recht viel kritik viel kritik
bekommen und in dasselbe horn stoßen die
herren fratzscher und hüter und
erstaunliche harmonie
es ist traurig dass man nun geneigt ist
den rentnerinnen und rentnern
nahezulegen einen umgekehrten enkeltrick
anzuwenden wenn zum beispiel der oper
einmal im jahr für eine stunde auf seine
enkelin aufpasst und dafür von seiner
tochter 12 euro mindestlohn im rahmen
eines minijobs oder aus selbständiger
tätigkeit bekommt dann hat er auch
anspruch auf die energiepreis pauschale
glauben sie dass man so vertrauen der
rentnerinnen und rentner gewinnen kann
heinrichs oft die waren mit unserer
nordrhein- westfälische sozialminister
karl josef laumann er fordert in seiner
bundesratsinitiative den empfängern von
alters und erwerbsminderungsrente die
energiepreis pauschale direkt mit den
renten auszuzahlen
wehrheim
wie bringen sie es über das herz gerade
denjenigen jetzt nicht zu helfen die es
am nötigsten brauchen die aktuellen
preissteigerungen sind besonders für
einkommensschwache haushalte
existenzgefährdend besonders in den
blick nehmen müssten sie gerade jetzt
die menschen die in verdeckter
altersarmut leben menschen die ansprüche
auf grundsicherung im alter haben diese
aber aus ganz unterschiedlichen gründen
leider oft aus scham nicht in anspruch
nehmen und das sind viele also stoppen
sie das ampel gehampel diskutieren sie
angemessen die probleme im zusammenhang
sorgen sie krisen politisch für eine
gerechte beteiligung der rentnerinnen
und rentner an den allgemeinen
entlastung und spielen sie
ordnungspolitisch nicht weiter auf zeit
kümmern sie sich endlich um eine
grundsätzliche reform der
alterssicherung die altersarmut
verhindert gerade in der krise müssen
die menschen der politik vertrauen
können verspielen sie dieses vertrauen
nicht leichtfertig vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
tanja machalet
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
heute ist freitag der dreizehnte und der
erzeugt der bei vielen menschen immer so
ein bisschen mulmiges gefühl und bei
einigen kollegen kollegen aus der cdu
hat man auch das den eindruck dass die
heute morgen so ein bisschen im falschen
fuß aufgestanden sind
aber ich muss sagen bei mir erzeugt der
tag heute und wirklich gutes gefühl denn
ich kann sagen wir halten das was wir
versprechen
mit dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf zur
anpassung beginnen wir damit das was wir
zur verbesserung bei der rente
versprochen und im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben umzusetzen und das ist
oft gezogen
ich möchte als erstes auch nochmal auf
die erwerbsminderungsrente eingehen denn
das was wir hiermit umsetzt ist wirklich
längst überfällig und es war um es noch
einmal deutlich zu sagen in den in der
vergangenen kollektionen mit der cdu
nicht machbar ist das dürfen sie und das
brauchen sie jetzt auch hier an dieser
stelle nicht zu leugnen
ich freue mich wirklich sehr dass wir
mit diesem gesetz nun die situation von
rund 303 millionen menschen zumindest
etwas verbessern können auf die details
wurde in der debatte ja schon intensiv
auch eingegangen und man kann sagen wir
haben einen wirklich guten gesetzentwurf
auf dem ministerium erhalten dafür und
dafür dass wir die verbesserungen so
schnell auf den weg bringen können bin
ich wirklich dankbar und
dennoch sehr auch ich und das hat der
kollege gerne es auch schon deutlich
gemacht dass es durchaus noch luft nach
oben gibt daran arbeiten wir daran
arbeite ich daran arbeitet meine
fraktion und 2 wir
setzen den nachholfaktor vorzeitig
wieder einen auch darauf ist bereits an
vielen stellen hingewiesen worden
darüber ist schon intensiv diskutiert
worden mit dem wir ausgefallene
rentenkürzungen in den voll in die
folgejahre nachziehen so steht es im
koalitionsvertrag und so werden wir es
machen daran halten wir uns
dass wir nicht die treibende kraft
hinter diesem vorhaben waren das ist nun
wirklich kein geheimnis
dennoch sehen auch hier dass die
vorzeitige reaktivierung des nach und
faktors uns langfristig gesehen
natürlich bei der finanzierung der
gesetzlichen rente helfen wird dabei ist
wichtig und das muss auch hier gesagt
werden der nachholfaktor darf nur soweit
angewandt werden dass das rentenniveau
nicht unter 48 prozent sinkt und ich
möchte auch noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass der nachholfaktor oder
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor den wir auch hier
mit kletten nicht zu verwechseln sind
das ist in der tat alles sei technisch
lieber kollege burgwald und wenn ich das
jetzt hier ausführlich erläutert würde
würde das die zeit springen mir ist
nämlich wichtig auch noch mal was zum
zum dritten punkt zur rentenerhöhung zu
sagen und ich will es auch noch einmal
deutlich sagen das ist die größere
rentenerhöhung seit fast 40 jahren in
westdeutschland mit 5,35 prozent im
osten sind es sogar 61 prozent 12
prozent und das ist in dieser zeit zu
dringend notwendig und das lassen wir
uns auch von niemandem hier kleinreden
[Musik]
und ich will auch darauf hinweisen dass
das alles nur möglich geworden ist weil
wir eben mit dem kurzarbeitergeld den
arbeitsmarkt stabil halten konnten und
ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass
es frau merkel oder die cdu warnt die
beim thema kurzarbeit die treibende
kraft waren das war unser bundesminister
a hubertus heil und die spd
und ja auch wir diskutieren jetzt schon
darüber wie wir rentnerinnen und rentner
in einem möglichen weiteren
entlastungspaket berücksichtigen können
auf die entlastungen die mit den
bestehenden paketen intendiert sind auch
für renten rentner ist
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
schon ausführlich eingegangen und das
müssen sie auch einfach zur kenntnis
nehmen aber nochmal zu erklärt zur
erhöhung zurück die führt dazu und das
ist ein ganz wichtiger aspekt dass der
rentenwert in denen nun zugegebenermaßen
nicht mehr ganz neuen bundesländern ab
diesem jahr 98,6 prozent des werts in
den alten bundesländern beträgt das
heißt bald haben wir endlich die
anpassung geschafft und wir müssen nicht
mehr differenzieren das ist ein enorm
wichtiger schritt für die weitere
einheit
mit dieser guten botschaft liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesen
schwierigen zeiten wünsche ich ihnen und
uns allen einen guten nachhauseweg ein
schönes wochenende
nächste woche sametime same place ich
freue mich auf die weiteren beratungen
im ausschuss herzlichen dank
tanja machalet at war die letzte
rednerin in dieser ersten beratung des
gesetzentwurfs der bundesregierung zur
rentenanpassung
2022 ist betrifft die empfänger
gesetzlichen rente aber es betrifft auch
die empfänger von
erwerbsminderungsrente auch da soll es
verbesserte leistungen geben in zukunft
es wird weiter diskutiert werden neben
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales und
dann werden wir das gesetz den
gesetzentwurf hier zu abschließenden
beratungen bald wiedersehen und
wiederhören
wie geht es weiter mit dem
tagesordnungspunkte 13 in dieser
sitzungswoche wehrhafte demokratie
gegenüber extremismus es der nächste
überschrift zugrunde liegt ein antrag
aus der unionsfraktion die sagt dass sie
zwar den aktionsplan der innenministerin
feser zum kampf gegen den
rechtsextremismus begrüße aber es müsse
weitere initiativen geben beispielsweise
gegen islamistischen terrorismus gegen
politischen islamismus sowie gegen
linksextremismus also alles was die
wehrhafte demokratie
möglicherweise oder die demokratie
insgesamt in gefahr bringen könnte
interessant dabei in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode hat es mehrere anläufe
gegeben innerhalb der großen koalition
und auch auf initiative der spd ein
demokratie fördergesetz zu verabschieden
das ist bei der union nicht
durchgedrungen jetzt also die
forderungen gegen extremismus auf der
auf verschiedenen ebenen allerdings sind
die schwerpunkte er gerichtet auf
maßnahmen die sich auf die abwehr und
damit auf die sicherheitsbehörden
richten mehr dazu von alexander throm
aus der unionsfraktion und da ist er
innenpolitischer sprecher
kollegen unsere demokratie wird von
vielen seiten angegriffen und deswegen
muss sie wehrhaft sein und die zahlen
von dieser woche zur politisch
motivierten kriminalität mahnt uns
erneut sind erneut auf einem höchststand
wir müssen dabei aber das gesamte
spektrum des extremismus in den blick
nehmen der staat muss mit aller
konsequenz jeglichen
verfassungsfeindlichen bestrebungen
entgegen treten und schon
horst seehofer hat den rechtsextremismus
als größte gefahr für unsere demokratie
bezeichnet und eine 89 punkte katalog
gegen rechtsextremismus auf den weg
gebracht er begrüße es außerordentlich
dass die jetzige bundesministerin diesen
weg fortführt und das eint uns auch im
kampf gegen den rechtsextremismus
mit der koalition vieles ist richtig an
dem zehn punkte plan den sie frau
ministerin feser vorgelegt haben aber es
ist nicht wirklich viel neues dabei
übernehmen viele der punkte die auch
schon die vorgängerregierung auf den weg
gebracht hat und frau ministerin sie
nutzen das thema ja schon auch um sich
selber ein bisschen zu promoten das ist
legitim das ist völlig in ordnung und
was sie da sagen ist auch nicht das
problem
das problem ist was sie nicht sagen
derzeit amtsantritt haben sie nahezu
nichts zu dem phänomen bereichen
linksextremismus oder islamistische
terror sowie politischer islam gesagt
sie vernachlässigen diese gefahren in
eklatanter art und weise eine werden
damen und herren
und dienst
und dies obwohl ihre eigene statistik
vom dienstag dieser woche zeigt dass die
gewaltbereitschaft bei den
linksextremisten besorgniserregend hoch
ist bei gewaltstraftaten also
körperverletzung und tötungsdelikten
liegen die linksextremisten auf platz
eins und dies obwohl ihre statistik
ausweist dass extremistische straftaten
aus religiöse ideologie im letzten jahr
um 50 prozent gestiegen sind das bka
wirklich die absolute mehrzahl der
straftaten mit terrorismus qualität
entfällt nach wie vor auf den phänomen
bereich religiöse ideologie das müsste
eine innenministerin alarmieren tut es
aber nichts jedenfalls haben sie dazu
nicht ausgeführt und deswegen die dieser
antrag auch dazu sie in diesem thema auf
die richtige spur zu bringen wir müssen
alle bereiche des extremismus
entsprechend berücksichtigen
und ehrlich gesagt hätte ich verstehe
auch nicht weshalb sie hier
bewusst so eine lücke entstehen lassen
denn nahezu alle maßnahmen ihres
zehn-punkte-plans könnten auch auf die
anderen extremismus formen angewandt
werden prävention aufklärung in schulen
sport betrieben kampf gegen hass und
hetze entwaffnung oder insbesondere auch
die aufdeckung der finanzströme
insbesondere auch im islamistischen
bereich wäre dringend geboten das ist
aber bei ihnen momentan nicht thema und
über den zehn-punkte-plan hinaus braucht
es mehr auch in dem für sie so wichtigen
thema des kampfes gegen
rechtsextremismus es braucht richtige
konsequente werkzeuge und die strukturen
bereich gefährdern aufklären zu können
bevor es zu spät ist aber daran fehlt es
bei ihrem aktionsplan gänzlich es fehlt
insbesondere dass wir unsere
sicherheitsbehörden auch technisch
entsprechend aufrüsten union und spd
haben beispielsweise in der letzten
periode dem verfassungsschutz die
befugnis übertragen zur quellen tk grüne
fdp haben die dazugehörige
rechtsverordnung im bundesrat blockiert
das erschwert die arbeit des
verfassungsschutzes weiter verweigern
sie dem bka beispielsweise die abwehr
des international bei der abwehr des
internationalen terrorismus auch das
auslesen von gespeicherter nachrichten
auf messenger diensten zu stellen dem
bka bei der strafverfolgung schlechter
als den verfassungsschutz deswegen
werden wir sie auch hier tätig zu werden
weiteres thema wir brauchen längere
löschen fristen bei der speicherung
denken sie an den mörder von walter
lübcke dadurch durchs raster gefallen
ist und wir brauchen ja auch bei
minderjährigen die möglichkeit
informationen speichern zu können denken
sie etwa an die vielen es rückkehrer
etwas das ihr präsident halten bank
schon seit langem fordert liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich muss feststellen die abneigung der
ampel gegenüber mehr befugnissen
vielleicht auch das misstrauen gegenüber
dem staat ist offensichtlich größer als
der wille des kampfes gegen extremismus
auch rechtsextremismus sonst würden sie
ihr handeln liebe kolleginnen kollegen
sie haben jetzt die verantwortung
sie haben auch die verantwortung dafür
was sie nicht tun was sie unterlassen
dieser verantwortung werden weder die
koalition noch die ministerin momentan
gerecht herzlichen dank
alexander throm der innenpolitische
sprecher der unions fraktion hat am ende
seiner rede noch mal in nancy faeser
angesprochen die
bundesministerin die an dieser debatte
natürlich teilnimmt nächster redner
jetzt unkraut aus der spd fraktion
er ist mitglied im ausschuss für inneres
und heimat und im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zu beginn
vielleicht zur einordnung atom sozial
den sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten und ich sage das
gleiche gilt für grüne und für freie
demokraten kämpfen nicht gegen rechts um
sich zu promoten sondern sie kämpfen aus
überzeugung heraus gegen rechts und
gegen alle feinde der demokratie das
wirklich gesagt haben und ich hoffe dass
das auch auf sie zutrifft und
was sie eben gesagt hatte mit dem
misstrauen gegen den staat und seine
institutionen möchte ich sie auch gerne
daran erinnern dass wir erstens schon
mal aus unserer geschichte heraus mit
unserem leben diesen staat verteidigt
haben im gegensatz zu ihnen und irgendwo
erfahren und dass wir zweitens in der
großen koalition gemeinsam mit ihnen und
stellen sie das doch nicht in abrede
acht jahre lang alles dafür getan haben
um die sicherheitsbehörden zu stärken
und diesen weg werden wir weitergehen
und ich erkläre ihnen auch gleich wie
wir das tun werden
und ich sage ihnen wenn sie in ihrem
antrag wonach dem zweiten absatz
aufgehört hätten zu schreiben womöglich
hätten wir ihm sogar zugestimmt aber
danach wenn man weiter ließ dann wird es
gerade zu gruselig in ihrem antrag
zumindest aus sicht unserer fraktion zum
beispiel die datenspeicherung von
kindern beim verfassungsschutz ein alter
ich sag's nicht ein alter wunsch ihrer
fraktion die straffung so nennen sie das
von präventionsprogrammen wir alle
wissen doch dass sie de facto damit
kürzungen im präventionsbereich meinen
außerdem wurden sie es eben gesagt am
allerdings natürlich lebenslänglich die
speicherung von personen beim
verfassungsschutz und auch nur absolut
aus der mottenkiste
gegriffen eine sogenannte
demokratieerklärung von denen die
demokratie arbeit und extremismus
prävention in diesem land leisten ihr
verhältnis sei gesagt ihr verhältnis zur
zivilgesellschaft ist geprägt von
misstrauen unseres von dank anerkennung
und vertrauen
aber
das ist eben der unterschied zwischen
ihnen und uns wir werden endlich das
demokratie fördergesetz beschließen und
eine solide und dauerhafte finanzierung
sicherstellen ihnen sind grundrechte bei
den befugnissen für unsere
sicherheitsbehörden nur im weg ein
hindernis für uns sind die grundrechte
der maßstab für alle befugnisse liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
sie haben ja gesagt die größte gefahr in
diesem land kommen von rechts und ich
finde sie sollten damit aufhören das
immer wieder zu relativieren schauen sie
in die aktuelle pmk statistik des
bundeskriminalamtes wir haben auch in
2021 doppelt so viele rechte straftaten
die linke ausländischen islamistische
sprachdaten zusammen doppelt so viele
wie alle anderen zusammen sie haben
sicher die fast verdreifachen der
straftaten in der kategorie nicht
zuzuordnen vernommen wir wissen dass sie
ein großer teil im zusammenhang mit der
korona leuten das zähne und corona
protesten steht die wiederum völkisches
antisemitisches unter rechtsextremes
gedankengut schlägt daher ist die gefahr
kein wunder dass die streif frau vom
staat daher ist die gefahr von rechts
garantiert noch größer als die pmk
statistik dies derzeit abbildet zu ihrem
gebetsmühlenartigen vorwurf zu viel
gegen rechts und zu wenig gegen
islamisten wir haben aktuell
75 rechte gefährder also personen denen
jederzeit einen rechtsextremistischen
terroranschlag zuzutrauen ist das
analyse tool zur einstufung der
gefährlichkeit ist beim
bundeskriminalamt übrigens erst seit ein
paar tagen im einsatz für islamisten
gibt es das schon sie wissen es seit
jahren und ich sage ihnen wir haben
nachholbedarf im kampf gegen rechts und
diese koalition wird das leisten
und es trifft sich gut dass sie hier ist
sozusagen als beleg dafür hat die
bundesinnenministerium heute mit dem
präsidenten des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz das lagebild
rechtsextremisten reichs bürger und
selbstverwalteten sicherheitsbehörden
vorgestellt bei 327 bediensteten der
sicherheitsbehörden von bund und ländern
wurden tatsächliche anhaltspunkte für
bestrebungen gegen die freiheitliche
demokratische grundordnung festgestellt
gemessen am dreijährigen
untersuchungszeitraum und gemessen an
der gesamtzahl von
355.000 100 beschäftigten in den
sicherheitsbehörden ist das natürlich
eine verschwindend geringe zahl
was für mich durchaus auch der beleg
dafür ist dass unsere
sicherheitsbehörden stabil auf dem boden
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung stehen aber trotzdem
natürlich ein jeder verfassungsfeind
zählt erst recht in den
sicherheitsbehörden keiner hat was
beides sicherheitsbehörden zu suchen und
deshalb ist es gut dass es ein
konsequentes vorgehen auch ihrer person
frau bundesinnenministerium dagegen gibt
und ein konsequentes vorgehen auch
dieser koalition und der ganzen
bundesregierung
den 360
grad blick den sie in ihrem antrag auch
fordern dann stellen wir gerade her wir
haben das ja miterlebt er war sozusagen
16 jahre so ein bisschen aus dem blick
geraten
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union wir waren uns unter den
demokratinnen und demokraten und das ist
mir wirklich wichtig zu sagen immer
einig dass extremismusbekämpfung und
extremismus prävention die grundpfeiler
unserer wehrhaften demokratie sind und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir hier an
einem strang ziehen damit demokratie
feinde nicht das vertrauen in den staat
untergraben können wenn sie diesen
konsens aufkündigt indem sie wie hier
einen generalverdacht gegen zivile
träger ins spiel bringen dann bewegen
sie sich als volkspartei weg von der
mitte ich sage das auch mit blick auf
andere parlamentarische eingaben von
ihnen fischen sie nicht am rechten rand
werben sie um wählerinnen und wählern in
der mitte der gesellschaft bleiben sie
volkspartei bleiben sie bleiben auch sie
stabil am boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung
vielen dank
politische spd-fraktion in der debatte
zu einem antrag der unionsfraktion
wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber
extremismus ist der titel und und diesen
antrag jetzt dürfen ja nicht aus der
fdp-fraktion mit seiner ersten rede im
parlament
pünktlich zur veröffentlichung der
fallzahlen der politisch motivierten
kriminalität im jahr 2021 bringt die
unions fraktion einen antrag zum thema
extremismus 1 die aktuellen zahlen im
bereich der pmk sind als dem sind für
uns als demokraten nicht gleichgültig im
bereich pmk rechts sind die straftaten
im vergleich zum jahr 2020 um rund 1600
fälle zurückgegangen im bereich pmk
links gab es einen rückgang von 800
fällen ein anstieg um 150 prozent ist
jedoch im bereich pmk der sich nicht
zuordnen lässt auf hold
wenn wir uns wenn wir uns mit den
begangenen straftaten befassen fällt auf
dass im jahr 20 21 von knapp 22.000
begangenen straftaten im bereich pmk
rechts mehr als die hälfte nämlich
12.000 taten propagandadelikte morgen
sprechen wir hingegen von
gewaltstraftaten also insbesondere von
körperverletzungen und tötungsdelikte
legen die im jahr 20 21 von
linksextremisten begangenen taten mit
1200 fällen nach wie vor noch vor denen
von rechtsextremisten begangenen taten
mit 1040 fällen erneut sind
linksextremisten spitzenreiter wenn es
darum geht andere menschen an der
gesundheit zu schädigen und
damit klar zu sagen jeder einzelne aus
extremistischen motiven heraus verübte
straftat ist eine zuviel und eindeutig
zu verurteilen
das heißt aber nicht dass der staat das
recht hat menschen aufgrund ihrer
meinung zu kriminalisieren und zu
extremisten zu planen als extremisten zu
brandt morgen einer pauschalen
verurteilung von menschen die
beispielsweise gegen corinna maßnahmen
spazierengehen treten wir entschieden
entgegen
es ist aber auch fröhlich zu sehen dass
die cdu inzwischen ihre sicherheits
politisches rückgrat entdeckt denn sie
hat recht wenn sie schreibt zum
staatlichen schutzauftrag gehört ein
blick der die bevölkerung im gleichen
maße von den erheblichen gefahren des
extremistischen islamismus wie vor dem
zunehmend radikalen linksextremismus
award schade ist allerdings dass ihr das
erst in der oppositionsrolle nach 16
jahren bundesregierung ein feld
andernfalls hätte sich schon in der
letzten wahlperiode den initiativen der
fdp fraktion zu stellen können
denn wenn die cdu heute befürchtet dass
unter nancy face oder kampf gegen
islamismus und linksextremismus in den
hintergrund tritt sage ich schon in der
wahlperiode
19 haben wir die prüfung von
verbotsverfahren gegen antifa banken die
unterbindung von finanzierung von
islamistischen moscheevereinen durch
ausländische staaten die ausweisung
ausländischer hassprediger und das
verbot islamistische moscheevereinen in
deutschland gefordert
immerhin adaptieren sie heute unsere
forderungen und schlagen eine aufdeckung
der finanzströme
von islamistischen moscheevereinen vfb
wirkt also
und wir als afd setzen uns auch weiter
konsequent für die stärkung in
anerkennung der polizei als wichtige
behörde der gefahren haben wir ein was
wir aber nicht brauchen sind weiter und
befugnisse für unsere
verfassungsschutzbehörden stephanie der
mörder von walter lübke war dem
verfassungsschutz bekannt anis amri
daten thema vom breitscheidplatz war dem
verfassungsschutz bekannt und das muss
man sich mal vorstellen da ein tank eine
26 jährige internet aktivisten ohne
schulabschluss einfach mal so aus
öffentlichen quellen und mit vollkommen
legalen mitteln die angeblichen behörden
bundes service telekommunikation und
transportmanagement bundesverwaltung als
vollständige tom organisationen des vs
300 mitarbeiter brauchen nunmehr neue
büros und neue identitäten die kosten
gehen in die millionen und das ist genau
der verfassungsschutz der auf ein
jährliches haushaltsbudget von einer
halben milliarde euro zurückgreifen kann
ich sage ihnen klar die innere
sicherheit wird am besten von unsere
polizei geschützt einen solchen
verantwortungs schutz brauchen wir nicht
ich freue mich auf die beratung im
ausschuss vielen dank
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen konstantin von notz und
konstantin von notz ist
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
und vorsitzender des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums für die nacht entlässt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
wehrhaftigkeit der demokratie muss sich
in diesen tagen ganz besonders beweisen
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung wird massiv bedroht von
innen wie von außen in einem lange nicht
mehr für möglich gehaltenen ausmaß aber
diese bedrohungen verlangen nach neuen
modernen differenzierten und rom vor
allen dingen auch verfassungskonform
sicherheitspolitischen antworten und da
findet man in ihrem antrag leider wenig
es ist vor allen dingen ein sammelsurium
ihrer alten
sicherheitspolitischen forderungen ihr
ziel ziemlich offenkundig in politische
profilschärfung zwei tage vor den wahlen
in nordrhein westfalen das verfehlen sie
meine damen und herren
und man muss es an dieser stelle einfach
mal sagen mit ihren hufeisen narrativen
unwissenschaftlichen hufeisen narrativen
haben cdu und csu hier lange viel zu
lange jahre lang die dringend notwendige
debatte über den mörderischen
rechtsextremismus in diesem land
verschleppt meine damen und herren über
200 morde
seit 1990 und die kurskorrektur atom die
kurskorrektur seit 2017 2018 war eine
von rechts terroristischen anschlägen
von einer skandalösen zunahme
rechtsextremistischer vereinigung und
aktivitäten getriebene kurskorrektur 13
untersuchungsausschüsse zum nsu eine
breite kritische berichterstattung die
zivilgesellschaft das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium dieses hauses und ein
wechsel an der spitze des bundesamtes
für verfassungsschutz war notwendig
damit das unions geführte
innenministerium endlich anerkennt was
lange offenkundig war nämlich dass
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung die sicherheit vieler
menschen in diesem land vor allen dingen
und massiv von rechtsextremisten
gefährdet
wer dazu eine klare sprache irgendwie
nachdenklich
fragen oder sowas einen neuen sound in
ihrem antrag sucht der sucht vergebens
es ist vor allen dingen alter wein in
alten schläuchen
jetzt haben wir alle jahr am letzten
sonntag nach schleswig holstein in den
hohen norden geguckt nach kiel manche
haben sich gefreut andere weniger auf
jeden fall hat ihr kollege herr czaja
messerscharf analysiert das läge
irgendwie an der wirtschaftspolitik und
dann kam es vor allen dingen an einer
sicherheitspolitischen null toleranz
politik das ist wirklich ein lustiges
statement denn sie werden in ganz
deutschland keinen bürgerrechts und
freiheitsrechte orientierten
koalitionsvertrag finden als den in
schleswig holstein gegen die dortige
koalition aufgeschrieben hat eben kein
platte null toleranz strategie sondern
eine an bürger und freiheitsrechten
orientierte innen und sicherheitspolitik
und da sage ich ihnen da lernen sie mal
was von ja die afg stellt man kalt nicht
indem man ihre abwegigen narrativen
nacherzählt sondern indem man klare
rechtsstaatliche kannte pferd
bemerkenswert ist ja der jüngste
gemeinsame beschluss der präsidien von
cdu und csu in sachen sicherheitspolitik
der durchaus selbstkritisch ausfällt ist
mir aufgefallen ich zitiere deutschland
ist militärisch und sicherheitspolitisch
hochgradig vokabel und weiter
strategisches denken und operative
wehrhaftigkeit müssen eine wesentlich
höhere politische priorität erhalten das
sind wahre worte gelassen ausgesprochen
nach 16 jahren durchgängiger
verantwortung von cdu und csu im
verteidigungsministerium und
innenministerium sieht es um diese
beiden zentralen felder sehr schlecht
aus und deswegen ist es wichtig und
richtig dass die ampelkoalition in
diesen bereichen einen besonders
ehrgeizig und schönen koalitionsvertrag
hat wir gehen es alles sagen die
hybriden bedrohungen die das
informationskampagnen die dramatischen
probleme bei der it sicherheit die wir
von ihm geerbt haben alle formen des
antisemitismus von rechts den aus der
mitte der gesellschaft und natürlich
auch den von links und den salafistisch
geprägten den rechtsextremismus genauso
wie den islamismus was sie petrom hier
so bedeutungsschwanger vortragen ist
eine vollkommene selbstverständlichkeit
wir müssen über alle hingucken wo es
gefährlich ist und das tun wir und
einsatzfreudig zum islamismus noch
loswerden weil ich den kollegen straffer
sehe und die kollegin mihalic und renner
im
untersuchungsausschuss zum
breitscheidplatz waren sie es die
gebremst haben und verschleppt haben die
aufklärung des schwersten salafistischen
anschlages in der bundesrepublik
deutschland der in ihrer verantwortung
passiert ist viele netzwerke und
probleme konnten wir nicht aufdecken
weil sie auf der bremse gestanden haben
auch in mecklenburg vorpommern bringen
und jetzt mal ein letzter punkt wegen
der wichtigkeit von rechtsstaatlichen
und verfassungskonformen antworten
drolliger weise nehmen sie ja bezug auf
die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
zum bayerischen landes
verfassungsschutzgesetz am 26 april
diesen jahres
monatelang hat die csu in einer wirklich
toll haften art und weise gegen die
gesamte staatsrechtslehrer gegen alle
die gefragt wurden könnte das eventuell
nicht doch verfassungskonform sein
dieses gesetz durchgebracht und sie
haben einen kollateralschaden
biblischen ausmaßes angerichtet weil
dieses urteil mal ganz viele instrumente
einfach abgeräumt und jetzt trauen sie
sich ernsthaft hier in den antrag zu
schreiben jetzt soll die ampel aber mal
schnell nach fähigen war leider viele
definitiven gemacht haben nicht
verfassungskonform sind das ist ein
treppenwitz meine damen und herren und
deswegen
kann man nur froh sein dass sich die
ampel auf den weg gemacht hat eine
seriöse
wissenschaftsbasierte evidenzbasierte
sicherheitspolitik zu machen und ich
freue mich auf unseren gemeinsamen weg
herzlichen dank
sagt konstantin von notz der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen in dieser
debatte über ein unionsantrag zum thema
wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber
extremismus und dazu spricht jetzt
martina renner aus der linksfraktion wo
sie innenpolitische sprecherin ist
der demokratischen fraktion ja für uns
demokratinnen und demokraten muss die
verteidigung von demokratie und
rechtsstaat gegen angriffe eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein es geht um
den schutz von leib und leben aller
menschen die in unserem land leben vor
dem hintergrund der anschläge der
letzten jahr bedeutet dies vor allem
dass wir gegen rassisten antisemiten und
neonazis kämpfen müssen und das
gemeinsame
cd prozess wurde hier diesen antrag
vorgelegt hat ist in den letzten 16
jahren bei der bekämpfung von
rassistischer gewalt und rechts terror
fulminant gescheitert sie hatten 16
jahre zeit das thema anzugehen
trotz der schlussfolgerung aus dem nsu
untersuchungsausschüssen ist nichts
passiert die morgen von hannah hanna und
kassel konnten geschehen und auch danach
wurde aus den reihen der union die von
rechten netzwerken ausgehende gefahr
banalisiert oder sogar schlimmer sie
leugneten zum beispiel um ein beispiel
zu nennen entsprechende strukturen im
polizei und bundeswehr
sie loben auch heute hier wir den
vormaligen innenminister seehofer dafür
dass er ende 2020 einen maßnahmenkatalog
zur bekämpfung von rechtsextremismus
erarbeitet habe ende 2020 neun jahre
nach der selbstheilung des nsu sowas
vorzutragen wäre mir peinlich
antrag heißt es auch dass es nach
mittlerweile sechs modern zum amt von
seitens der innenministerin feser an
einer grundhaften befassung mit den
gefahren des islamistischen terrorismus
bangel
islamistischer terrorismus ist eine
gefahr für die demokratie
dann habe ich aber eine frage was haben
schäuble der messias kannst dass du dich
auch der war mal innenminister wir haben
fast vergessen und horst seehofer getan
wenn die innenminister der cdu csu und
geliefert hätten dann bräuchten sie
diesen antrag gar nicht
ich muss meinen kollegen
konstantin von notz recht geben was er
hier zum teil scheidplatz
untersuchungsausschuss gesagt hat das
innenministerium unter sofort alles
dafür getan um die aufklärung des
anschlags zu blockieren und es gibt ein
zweites nach islamistischen wie rechts
terroristischen anschlägen sind cdu und
csu nicht bereit wäre in stein
gemeißelten annahmen über das
funktionieren der sicherheitsarchitektur
zu überdenken und genau diese haltung
spiegelt auch ihr antrag wieder
das liegt auch daran dass hier wieder
vor allem um extremisten geht links
rechts hauptsache ist muss sie folgen
stur den begrifflichkeiten des
geheimnisses die mitte ist vermeintlich
schön raus dann habe ich eine zweite
frage an sie wenn ihnen der
verfassungsschutz heiliges warum haben
sie dann maßen zu ihrem chef gemacht
die einstellungen die sich hier mit
ihrem antrag bekämpfen wollen bis heute
zur causa maßen aufklärung fairen zeigen
was man es auch sein noch ein wort zur
neuen bundesregierung wie soll
gefahrenanalyse gelingen wenn über
23.000 straftaten haben die bpm tat
nicht zuzuordnen landen diese einstufung
konterkarierte den ursprünglichen zweck
der statistik 2001 eingeführt um endlich
ein rechtes ein realistisches bild zu
rechten tötungsdelikten zu bekommen ich
glaube hier muss die bundesregierung
halben handeln und diese falsche und
ihre leitende einordnen offensichtlicher
recht der gewalt und straftaten zu
ändern vielen dank
martina renner für die linksfraktion und
ihr wird jetzt folgen linda teuteberg
aus der fdp-fraktion mitglied im
ausschuss für inneres und heimat
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dass unsere demokratie wehrhaft
sein müssen nach innen und nach außen
dass es wahrlich offensichtlicher in
diesen tagen als es eigentlich schon
zuvor war das zeigt der russische
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine und es
zeigen leide auch die neuesten zahlen
zur politisch motivierten kriminalität
die die bundesinnenministeriums in
dieser woche vorgestellt hat sie zeigen
einen neuen höchststand und das in
vielen bereichen in vielen bereichen von
extremismus verschiedenen phänomen
bereichen politisch motivierter
kriminalität und was wir nicht brauchen
das ist auch nicht anders als noch in
den letzten jahren ist irgendein ranking
oder hierarchien welche art von
extremismus oder kriminalität schlimmer
oder weniger schlimm sei oder die
größere bedrohung wir brauchen den
rundumblick und das klare eintreten des
freiheitlichen rechtsstaates gegen
jeglichen extremismus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch gegen jede form der menschen oder
demokratie verachtung es gibt keinerlei
die überlegenheit irgendeine ausprägung
von extremismus und es kann übrigens
auch für menschenverachtung keinen
rabatt geben weder kulturell noch für
irgendein politisches lager wo immer wir
sie wahrnehmen
[Musik]
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen besonders
beschämend und besorgen müssen uns die
auch erneut auf einem höchststand
befindlichen zahl antisemitischer taten
wir haben eine besondere verantwortung
dafür dass jüdisches leben in unserem
land sicher und selbstbestimmt
stattfinden kann und dafür dass nicht
wir uns das attestieren sondern das
jüdinnen und juden selbst darauf
vertrauen
und deshalb gilt
egal in welchem gewand egal in welcher
ausprägung jede form des antisemitismus
ist gleichermaßen inakzeptabel und wir
müssen ja entschieden entgegentreten als
rechtsstaat als gesellschaft und auch
jeder und jede einzelne von uns wo sie
uns in gesprächen begegnen zu
widersprechen wir müssen die
gesellschaftlichen türen gegen anti
gegen antisemitismus gegen
menschenverachtendes gedankengut fest
verschließen damit es auf reale türen
wir in halle nicht ankommt
und
das finde ich übrigens einen seltsamen
kontrast zwischen dem aktuellen
wirklichen ernst der lage einerseits und
den alten reflexen die in dieser debatte
wieder auftauchen und ich will da zwei
beispiele nennen zum allen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen von der union das
ist nicht der richtige anlass für die
altbekannten forderungen
natürlich muss der rechtsstaat wehrhaft
sein und da muss man auch sachlich über
befugnisse diskutieren können aber hier
wie in anderen bereichen geht das
zauberwort unserer verfassung
verhältnismäßigkeit und dann daran hat
sich nichts verändert
und zum anderen
weil eben neue phänomene ehe eine neue
nachdenklichkeit erfordern und nicht die
alten reflexe muss ich auch zu den
kollegen der linken sagen verändern wenn
wir neue schwer einzuordnende phänomene
haben dann finde ich besser ist besser
dass das auch offen kommuniziert wird
bei der kriminalitätsstatistik als wie
sie vorschnell phänomene in alten
schubladen zu packen war das in ihr
weltbild besser passt verschwörungs
erzählungen und vieles andere gibt es
nicht nur in einem politischen lager und
ich finde das sollte uns eher
nachdenklich machen so sehr die
sicherheitsbehörden gegen jeden der den
staat delegitimieren will klar vorgehen
müssen sollten wir über die ursachen und
die motive gründlich nachdenken und
nicht alles so wie sie es gern möchten
in eine rechte schublade packen sondern
die komplexität der phänomene wahrnehmen
und beschreiben
und ebenfalls endlich und die müssen uns
besorgen sind die erhöhten zahlen bei
angriffen gegen mandats und amtsträger
auch hier müssen wir ganz klar sagen wer
repräsentanten unserer demokratie
unseres rechtsstaates angreift greift
uns alle an und das ist keine frage der
politischen opportunität der mandats und
amtsträger angreift der zeigt damit auch
seinen mangelnden respekt zb vor den
wahl entscheidungen der bürgerinnen und
bürger die diese personen legitimiert
haben hier darf es kein verständnis
dafür geben wir müssen glaubwürdig dafür
einstehen dass unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung so viele
friedliche und legale möglichkeiten
bietet sich politisch zu beteiligen und
da kann es auch keinen blankoscheck
geben für selbsternannte aktivisten
recht und gesetz gelten für jedermann in
unserem land frau teuteberg gestorben
eine zwischenfrage
darin vorsorge für unsere demokratie
das muss für uns auch bedeuten respekt
vor dem ehrenamt zum beispiel auch in
politischen parteien bessere
rahmenbedingungen für das ehrenamt in
unserem land darauf kommt es an wir
brauchen vieles mehr vorbeugung
prävention politische bildung dazu wird
mein kollege stephan weiter sprechen
auch auf unser verhalten in jeder
politischen debatte kommt es an wie groß
der respekt für die politischen
institutionen in unserem land ist vielen
dank
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
hat das wort zu einer kurzintervention
die kollegin renner
danke frau vorsitzende dass sie mir die
gelegenheit geben auf die ausführungen
kollegin teuteberg einzugehen sie haben
mir vorgeworfen dass wir die neuen
phänomene wie sie es nennen in der
korona leugne szene so unrecht rechts
bezeichnet
diese seien vielmehr indifferent in
ihrer politischen bewertung ich will
ihnen sagen das was wir dort vorfinden
sind nicht einfach verschwörungs
erzählung das sind antisemitische motive
die weit zurückgehen auch in die
vergangenheit es sind
sozialdarwinistische vorstellung das
recht der stärkere soll sich durchsetzen
sie bekämpfen den staat um ein
autoritäres regime zu errichten sie
lehnen die institutionen sie können alle
einstellungs ebenen des
rechtsextremismus durchgehend sie finden
alle diese facetten auch den rassismus
zum beispiel in diesem anti asiatischen
moment in der dort auch gefunden haben
in der korona leuten dass sie die wir
müssen endlich anerkennen sie ist das
ergebnis einer rechten mobilisierung und
einer rechten ideologie danke
sie dürfen antworten sie
kollegin renner sie bestätigen gerade
mit ihren einlassungen all das was ich
meinte nämlich gegen die im wege dass es
sowohl an diesem es muss leider auch
autoritäres denken und vieles mehr nicht
nur in einem politischen lager gibt dass
es das auch auf der linken seite durch
ausgibt und vereinfachte
geschichtsbilder all das bestätigen sie
leider damit ich habe keine einordnung
vorgenommen sondern haben beschrieben
den respekt davor dass wenn
sicherheitsbehörden ist eine tat nicht
eindeutig einem bestimmten politischen
seite zuordnen können dass man das dann
auch so redlich kommunizieren sollte und
dass wir uns mit neuen phänomen
auseinandersetzen sollten hat eben
nichts mit verharmlosung sondern mit
ernsthaftigkeit zu tun
wir fahren fort in der debatte nächster
redner für die cdu csu fraktion ist dr
stefan hack
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie das haben die väter
und mütter unseres grundgesetzes so
festgelegt aus gutem grund die
geschichte war ihr bitterer lehrmeister
und den jahrzehnten in denen unsere
verfassung nun geltung hat waren wir
immer wieder mit neuen herausforderungen
konfrontiert das gilt für die äußere
sicherheit aber insbesondere auch für
die innere sicherheit unseres landes
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
am dienstag von der
bundesinnenministerium vorgestellt
statistik zum jahr 2021 und den dort
politisch motivierten straftaten gibt
uns allen anlass zur sorge 2021 gab es
im vergleich zum vorjahr mit einem
zuwachs von 23 prozent einen deutlichen
anstieg von politisch motivierten
straftaten mit über 55.000 delikten
befindet sich die politisch motivierte
kriminalität auf dem höchsten stand seit
der einführung dieser statistik im jahr
2001 und insbesondere der anstieg sie
haben es gesagt vor kollegen heute berg
antisemitischer gewalt hatten um 29
prozent
ist erschreckend und bedarf einer
entschlossenen reaktion auf seiten von
staat und gesellschaft
die kolleginnen kollegen der mord an dr
walter lübke der rassistisch motivierte
anschlag von hanau
und auch der anti semitische anschlag in
halle haben uns jungs dorf äußerst
schmerzhafte art und weise vor augen
geführt dass rechtsextreme gewalt noch
immer die größte gefahr für unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
darstellt da ist richtig dass die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung in den
vergangenen mai unter der federführung
von bundesinnenminister seehofer ins
leben gerufen 89 punkte plan umgesetzt
hat und sie das gestehen wir gerne zu
hier nochmal eigene schwerpunkte gesetzt
haben aber wir dürfen dort nicht stehen
bleiben zur wahrung unserer freiheit
muss politischer extremismus jeglicher
couleur bekämpft werden und deshalb
wundern wir uns schon frau ministerin
warum nach einem knappen halben jahr im
amt wir noch keine konkreten maßnahmen
zum kampf gegen islamistischen gegen
extremistischen islamismus von ihnen
kennen anschläge wie auf dem berliner
breitscheidplatz wie in paris nur wenn
wir 2015 haben unseren ganzen kontinent
ins herz getroffen und die gefahr durch
islamistischen terror auch hier in
deutschland ist weiterhin hoch wir
fordern daher ein entschlossenes
vorgehen und die erarbeitung eines
aktionsplans gegen radikale islamisten
islamistische bestrebungen auch hier in
deutschland dafür
dafür brauchen unsere
sicherheitsbehörden eine gute
personalausstattung vor allem aber das
richtige handwerkszeug wir haben das in
der von uns geführten regierung ist
möglich und mit großem nachdruck
verfolgt und ich möchte sie hier
weiterhin auffordern starten sie den
verfassungsschutz insbesondere im
bereich der
telekommunikationsüberwachung mit
weitreichenden befugnissen aus schaffen
sie die voraussetzungen dafür um die
bestmögliche überwachung terroristischer
gruppen zu ermöglichen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir im auftrag
des staates mit öffentlichen
fördermitteln im bereich der extremismus
prävention tätig wird er muss und das
ist uns schon wichtig auf dem boden
unseres grundgesetzes stehen und deshalb
fordern wir die einführung einer
demokratie treueerklärung in
förderbescheiden damit träger
insbesondere von präventionsprojekten
sich eindeutig zum fundament unserer
gemeinsamen werteordnung bekennen
wir dürfen jedenfalls nicht akzeptieren
wir dürfen nicht akzeptieren wenn
diejenigen die rechtsextremismus und
rassismus bekämpfen wollen gleichzeitig
hass und gewalt gegen polizei und unsere
sicherheitskräfte führen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren auch der
militanten linksextremismus stellt in
deutschland eine schwerwiegende
bedrohung dar ich finde das sollten wir
hier nicht unerwähnt lassen frau
kollegin wenn gewalttätige aufmärsche
tätliche angriffe auf polizei auf
sicherheitsbehörden sind leider keine
seltenheit
wir fordern dass sie sich darum stärker
kümmern wir brauchen eine bessere
aufklärung der linksextremistischen
szene und gegen die zunehmende
radikalisierung und gewaltbereitschaft
linksextremistischer gruppierungen
schützen sie unsere demokratie und
stärken sie unsere sicherheitsbehörden
und zwar ohne scheuklappen unsere
unterstützung es liegen aber sicherlich
stefan hack aus der unionsfraktion wird
und am ende seiner rede noch mal die
gefahr von links durch linksextremisten
die bundesinnenministerium hat heute
morgen einen bericht zu
rechtsextremisten in den
sicherheitsbehörden vorgelegt und
festgestellt dass unter den bediensteten
der sicherheitsbehörden von bund und
ländern innerhalb von drei jahren
327 mitarbeiter aufgefallen sind die
bezüge zum rechtsextremismus oder zur
szene der sogenannten reichs bürger und
selbst verwalter haben hier am pult
jetzt
p&g schierenbeck aus der spd-fraktion
antrag den rechtsextremismus ist derzeit
für die größte gefahr für unser
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
und nicht nur ich stimme an dieser
stelle mit der union über ein sondern
die gesamten fraktionen der csp den
grünen und der fdp das können sie sogar
nachlesen koalitionsvertrag seit der 107
zahlen der
3587 ich zitiere
rechtsextremismus ist derzeit die größte
bedrohung unserer demokratie
die zahlen zeigen eindeutig dass die
fälle von rechts motivierter
kriminalität sehr hoch sind höher als
die der linken die der religiösen oder
die der ausländischen ideologie die
zahlen zeigt auch wie dringend es ist
gegen den rechtsextremismus wirksam
vorzugehen wenn die von rechtem
gedankengut
geprägten straftaten doppelt so hoch
sind wie die der linken dann muss uns
doch allen zeigen dass wir zuerst
dagegen vorgehen müssen dass wir uns
erst damit beschäftigen müssen dem hass
und der hetze und der gewalt von rechts
einhalt zu gebieten
verstehen sie mich richtig jede straftat
ist eine zu viel jede gewaltanwendung
ist zu verurteilen
denn wir haben auch schon
linksextreme ausschreitungen gesehen
bilder von fernen menschen die autos
anzünden um systemkritik auszudrücken
das ansinnen eines autos ist aber keine
systemkritik das ist erstmal
sachbeschädigung sachbeschädigung ist
übrigens auch das feld in dem von links
motivierte täter
sich am häufigsten betätigen und damit
möchte ich zum nächsten punkt kommen
sachbeschädigung ist die beschädigung
einer sache es wird etwas beschmierte
kaputtgemacht angezündet das wird mit
aller konsequenz nach als strafrechtlich
verfolgt dennoch können wir diese dinge
reparieren was wir nicht reparieren
können das sind die angriffe auf die
seele seines fremdenfeindliche
antisemitische
islamfeindlich oder volksverhetzende
äußerungen äußerungen gegen die sexuelle
orientierung oder identität all diese
äußerungen hinterlassen spuren in den
lebens biografien von menschen das sind
verletzungen kunden die nicht sichtbar
sind und die die geschädigten oft ihr
ganzes leben lang mit sich tragen werden
solche äußerungen kommt in der masse von
rechts und deswegen lohnt es sich zu
sagen dass rechtsextremismus nicht nur
unsere demokratie bedroht sondern uns
demokratinnen bereits angreift
fremdenfeindlichkeit antisemitismus oder
volksverhetzung sind häufig nicht so gut
zu erkennen wie zum beispiel ein
brennendes auto und genau weil diese
angriffe auf die demokratie so schwer zu
erkennen sind sollten wir mit aller
macht daran arbeiten sie als erste zu
verhindern wir müssen mit aller kraft
den aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus
umsetzen wir dürfen die opfer von
rechtsextremisten nicht allein lassen
und wir müssen mandatsträger ihnen vor
angriffen schützen wir müssen eine
demokratische streitkultur fördern die
politische bildung stärken und die
medienkompetenz steigern
wir müssen die hetze im internet
bekämpfen verschwörungs ideologien
entkräften und so der radikalisierung
vorbeugen wir müssen rechtsextremist in
den entwaffnen und rechtsextreme
netzwerke zerschlagen
wir müssen mit sachverstand daran
extremismus in jeder form zu bekämpfen
gefühle sind ein schlechter berater wenn
es um nichts weniger geht also um unsere
demokratie
wir brauchen mehr erkenntnisse wenn wir
extrem ist ihnen effektiv bekämpfen
wollen die periodische
sicherheitsbericht wird uns langfristig
dabei helfen tendenzen und ursachen zu
erkennen und lösungsansätze zu finden
ich habe zu beginn meiner rede die
koalitionsvertrag erwähnt dass die
koalition der cdu csu bestimmt es tut
mir leid wenn sie den eindruck gewonnen
haben dass wir uns nicht nur mit den
dringendsten und größten problemen
beschäftigen es geht natürlich weiter im
koalitionsvertrag ich zitiere wir treten
alle verfassungsfeindlichen
gewaltbereiten bestrebungen entschieden
entgegen
rechtsextremismus islamismus
verschwörungs ideologien
linksextremismus oder jede andere form
von extremismus
sehr verehrte damen und herren
weiter und wenn du bis
2021 war das innenministerium in der
hand der union die in ihrem antrag
selbst schreibt dass die zahl der
extremisten seit jahren zunimmt und
scheinbar haben sie viel zu wenig
unternommen um dieser entwicklung
einhalt zu gebieten nun haben wir mit
nancy faeser eine kluge und starke frau
die mit entschlossenheit und
fachkenntnisse amt ausübt mit ihr
gemeinsam werden wir als fortschritt
gewandte koalition entschieden gegen
jegliche art von extremismus vorgehen
dem antrag der cdu csu und werden nichts
mit dem ersten
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
bild schierenbeck war das aus der spd
fraktion die am ende ihrer rede noch mal
auf den früheren bundesinnenminister
verwiesen hat
der union vor hält deshalb im bereich
extremismus in den vergangenen jahren zu
wenig getan zu haben der nächste redner
in dieser debatte ist christian wirth
und er kommt aus der fdp
also bei manchen vorredner und aus dem
linken spektrum von giorgio ein glaube
keiner statistik die du nicht selbst
gefälscht hast der vorliegende antrag
der cdu csu fraktion enthält viel das
richtig kein wunder es sind einige
forderungen die wir bereits in der
letzten legislaturperiode gefordert
haben extremismus ob von links oder
islamistisch oder natürlich auch
rechtsextremismus muss bekämpft werden
es freut uns dass mittlerweile auch die
union die einseitige fokussierung auf
dem phänomen bereich rechtsextremismus
durch ministerin feser kritisiert auch
die forderung nach der erneuten
einführung der sogenannten
extremismusklausel unterstützen wir
ausdrücklich es handelt sich dabei um
eine der ersten anträgen der fraktionen
in der letzten legislaturperiode die
extremismusklausel soll kurz gesagt
verhindern dass linksextremistische und
islamistische strukturen übersteuern
verdeckt finanziert werden welche für
den kampf gegen rechtsextremismus
ausgelobt werden
abgeschafft wurde der extremismusklausel
für die cdu/csu zur erinnerung von
manuela schwesig im einvernehmen mit
thomas de maizière im kabinett drei
unter merkel
wie wichtig auch der kampf gegen
linksextremismus ist zeigt die ende
april erfolgte anschlagsserie auf
ladengeschäfte des modelabels thor
steinar in der bundesweit konzertierten
aktion erfolgt zeitgleich mehrere farb
und buttersäure anschläge bei denen auch
personen und tiere zu schaden kam
trauriger höhepunkt war die tat in
erfurt bei der auf eine wehrlose auf dem
boden liegende frau von mehreren
maskierten linksextremisten mit
schlagstöcken auf kopf beine und füße
eingedroschen wurde anschließend wurde
das opfer zum abschied noch reizgas ins
gesicht gespürt der fall erinnert an das
vorgehen der linksextremistische
gefährder zelle um nina engel die gefahr
durch islamismus die uns allen große
sorge bereiten sollte möchte ich anhand
folgender zahlen verdeutlichen im jahre
20 21 leitete generalbundesanwalt für
folgende phänomenbereich
ermittlungsverfahren ein
rechtsextremismus terrorismus sechs
verfahren
linksextremismus terrorismus zehn
islamistisch motivierte extremismus
terrorismus ganze
258 verfahren so viel wie meisten gefahr
geht von rechts aus jetzt wirklich der
von der union geforderte großzügige
ausweitung der befugnisse für den
verfassungsschutz möchte ich der
kollegen ortsrats vorhin erwähnt an die
ohrfeige des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
bezüglich das sicherheitsgesetz der cdu
in bayern erinnern
generell würde ist in allen gut tun die
den instrumentierten verfassungsschutz
unterstützt haben die letzte
legislaturperiode
wenn er nicht mit dem innenministerium
unterstellt werde sondern politisch
neutral agieren können denn hier sollten
wir uns gedanken machen der überweisung
stimmen wir zu vielen dank
vielen dank herr wird
als nächste lettern das wort die
kollegin dr bündnis 90/die grünen und
sie es erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin der fraktion
segert der präsident meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union mit ihrem antrag haben sie
gleich mehrere alte kamellen aus der
schublade gekramt das haben meine
vorrednerin und vorredner ihnen schon
eindrücklich dargelegt mehr überwachung
von kommunikation gerne auch von
minderjährigen misstrauen gegenüber
zivilgesellschaftlichen initiativen et
cetera pp kann man alles nachlesen
aber wenn wir zurückblicken auf die
letzten 16 jahre da können wir
feststellen dass diese zeit gerade nicht
von einem erfolgreichen kampf gegen
extremisten und staatsfeinde geprägt war
ganz im gegenteil man könnte sogar von
einer wohlfühl zeit für rechtsextreme
und islamisten sprechen
der nicht verhindert zu anschlag auf dem
breitscheidplatz der nsu die anschläge
in halle und hanau der mord an dr walter
lübke die massive rechtsextrem und
islamistische vernetzung all das fand
unter den augen der sicherheitsbehörden
stadt als sie von der union
verantwortung getragen haben und wenn
man sich jetzt ihren antrag anschaut
dann fragt man sich schon warum sie zum
beispiel als die aktionspläne die sie
jetzt vollmundig fordern die übrigens
völlig inhaltsleer sind nicht schon
früher erarbeitet haben denn die
sicherheitsprobleme mit den aktuellsten
doch nicht nur wir sind doch jetzt nicht
plötzlich nach der bundestagswahl vom
himmel gefallen ich kann ihnen gar nicht
aufzählen mit wie vielen anträgen
kleinen anfragen unzähligen debatten
hier im deutschen bundestag in etlichen
untersuchungsausschüssen haben wir fast
schon verzweifelt versucht sie
wachzurütteln meine damen und herren
aber stattdessen haben sie sich an
instrumente geklammert die entweder
verfassungswidrig sind wie sie
regelmäßig bescheinigt bekommen haben
oder völlig nutzlos waren und genau das
machen sie jetzt weiter sie sind
inhaltlich leergelaufen meine damen und
herren
ein wechsel an der spitze des
innenministeriums war dringend nötig und
im koalitionsvertrag beschäftigen wir
uns intensiv mit der aufarbeitung der
sicherheitspolitik der letzten jahre die
enorme bedeutung der zivilgesellschaft
im kampf gegen rassismus antisemitismus
rechtsextremismus und jegliche formen
der demokratiefeindlichkeit wurde
einfach viel zu lange von ihnen verkannt
wir sehen das schon lange und haben sie
auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
dass diese sicherheitsprobleme ohne die
wichtige arbeit zivilgesellschaft
zivilgesellschaftlicher initiativen
nicht zu lösen sind radikalisierung
spiralen durchbricht man eben nicht mit
der überwachung minderjähriger oder mit
ausrufen kommunikationsüberwachung oder
mit extremismus klausel in
förderanträgen sondern mit erprobten die
radikalisierung programm und
vernünftiger prävention das know how ist
vorhanden wir müssen besser nutzen
mit dem demokratie fördergesetz werden
wir die arbeit von
zivilgesellschaftlichen initiativen
strukturell absichern und damit den
kampf gegen demokratie und
menschenfreundlichkeit massiv stärken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
nicht nur mendes untersuchungsausschuss
sondern auch mit vielen hier anwesenden
kollegen mit herrn von notz mit martina
renner mit benjamin strasser im
untersuchungsausschuss zum anschlag auf
dem breitscheidplatz mitgearbeitet und
über ihre nicht erfolg der aufklärung
diesem zusammenhang gerade sie atom also
was sie sich hier gerade getraut haben
ist schon wirklich stark ja wenn man ihr
engagement diese basiert ins ausschuss
nochmals revue passieren lässt
aber wir haben uns in diesen ausschüssen
auch wirklich intensiv mit
extremistischen bedrohungen auch mit der
vernetzung gefasst aber vor allem auch
mit der extrem reformbedürftigen
sicherheitsarchitektur die ampel
koalition geht das jetzt an wir werden
die sicherheitsarchitektur einer
gesamtbetrachtung unterziehen und die
arbeit auf allen ebenen effektiver
machen wir werden die analysefähigkeit
der sicherheitsbehörden stärken die
grenzüberschreitende polizeiliche
zusammenarbeit verbessern und mit einer
gesamtstrategie aus prävention die
radikalisierung und effektiver
gefahrenabwehr die extremismusbekämpfung
entscheidend voranbringen
wir werden uns weiter
wissenschaft mit der realisierung von
sogenannten querdenkern befassen eine
absolute notwendigkeit angesichts der
hohen gewaltbereitschaft und der
massiven desinformationskampagne die wir
seit beginn der pandemie erleben und
jetzt sehen wir wie die gleichen
verschwörungs ideologen mit den putin
verschwören mitlaufen das darf jetzt
nicht aus dem blick geraten meine damen
und herren
noch eine bemerkung zum schluss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union
ehemaliger bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer hat erkannt dass vom
rechtsextremismus die größte bedrohung
für die demokratie ausgeht das haben sie
ja auch in ihrem antrag geschrieben
bevor dann aber das große aber kommt tun
sie sich doch bitte einen gefallen und
uns allen auch fallen sie mit ihrer
hufeisen logik nicht hinter diese
erkenntnis zurück sondern unterstützen
sie uns jetzt bei dem was nun zu tun ist
vielen
vielen dank irene mihalic für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen war
übrigens früher mal polizeibeamtin hat
dann polizei wissenschaften und
kriminologie studiert mit abschluss im
buch nächste rednerin in dieser debatte
ist petra nicolaisen aus der
unionsfraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in genau
zehn tagen steht er 73 jahrestag des
grundgesetzes bevor und das grundgesetz
herrkoerper doch die wehrhaftigkeit
unserer demokratie ein fundament das
bewusst ein schutzmechanismus gedacht
ist um unsere demokratische um unser
staatsverständnis wo missbrauch zu
schützen und unsere werte zu bewahren
und auch wenn unsere verfassung auf
papier geschrieben ist das grundgesetz
ist für mich ein reißfestes fundament
und das muss es auch bleiben
das bedeutet und das bedeutet natürlich
gerade jetzt dass die bundesregierung
mehr dafür tun muss die geistigen und
gewalttätigen angriffe auf unsere
verfassung müssen verhindert werden vom
ministerium diese angriffe dürfen nicht
zur zerreißprobe für unsere
demokratischen und freiheitlichen
grundsätze werden liebe frau ministerin
die zahlen auf es ist eben schon
eingegangen worden die sie am montag
veröffentlicht haben zum anstieg
politisch motivierter straftaten
machen es ganz deutlich es besteht
handlungsbedarf
und das in nahezu wie bereits berichtet
in allen bereichen gegen hass
kriminalität im internet gegen
fremdenfeindlichkeit und antisemitismus
gegen gewalt sowohl an bürgerinnen und
bürgern politikerinnen und politikern
und gegen die polizei
und die zahlen sprechen
und diese ansprechend zugleich für eine
genauere erkennung der straftaten das
müssen wir mit konsequenten maßnahmen
bekämpfen und flankieren denn wehrhafte
demokratie bedeutet für mich dass der
start dieser konfrontation nicht aus dem
wege geht er stellt sich gewalt
ausgrenzung und spaltung entgegen unter
braucht es keine lippenbekenntnisse
vielmehr braucht es auch wirkungs
stärkere befugnisse und deshalb muss der
grundsatz gelten wenn politisch
motivierte kriminalität spürbar wird und
das wird sie dann muss auch die antwort
des staates darauf spürbar und
konsequent sein und ist darf kein zögern
mehr geben damit muss schluss sein
es bleibt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ein zweifel und zugleich die frage wofür
die bundesregierung eigentlich steht
will die bundesregierung eine leuchtturm
politik die nach außen hin scheint aber
das innere nicht wirklich beleuchtet
oder wollen sie eine politische realität
gestalten die es nicht schafft vertrauen
in staat und gemeinschaft sowie die
grundsätze von demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu wahren
oder wollen sie wirklich entschieden
gegen demagogie extremisten und rasse
die die streitbarkeit unserer demokratie
missbrauchen vorgehen der vorliegende
antrag meiner fraktion ist aus diesem
grund ein weckruf an die bundesregierung
zeigen sie haltung ergreifen sie die
möglichkeiten um den feinden der
demokratie dem hass dem terror und der
gewalt sowie auch der angst und der
verschwörung und der verleumdung und
allen ihren techniken das handwerk legen
zu können
deshalb
[Applaus]
deshalb fordern wir sie auf
und ich würde die vier punkte im kern
gern noch mal wiederholen setzen sie
endlich einen aktionsplan auf gegen
islamistischen terror und gegen
linksextremismus überprüfen sie die
wirksamkeit von präventionsprogrammen
und lieber kollege krutsch da geht es in
keinster weise um kürzungen stärken sie
auch die sicherheits und justizbehörden
für eine bessere erkennung und
bekämpfung und besonders um den
betroffenen menschen zu helfen und zu
schützen und viertens starten sie
endlich die behörden mit wirksameren
befugnissen aus eine bundesregierung
muss schließlich bewahren was wir aus
überzeugung vertreten und tüten und die
fundamente einer gesunden demokratie die
frühe kunst und freiheit der menschen
wie möglich ist rezept dafür haben wir
ihnen vorgelegt jetzt sind sie am ziel
und an
jetzt sind sie gefordert zu entscheiden
und lieber kollege kratzen euch bitten
kann die letzte legislaturperiode
einsatz herr präsident bitte ich
erinnere mich an eine eigentlich ganz
gute zusammenarbeit aber ihre rede eben
ging unter die gürtellinie und wenn
einer die sicherheitsbehörden nicht
gestärkt hat in der letzten
legislaturperiode dann war es die spd
vielen dank für leisen sohlen schließen
holstein erinnerungen der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der cdu
fraktion kann sich schon mal darauf
einstellen dass hoffmann nur noch 4
minuten statt fünf minuten nicht als
nächster redner taktik kollege dr stefan
seite
fdp-fraktion das wort mit seiner ersten
parlaments-
bürgerpräsident serie von ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen hier
debattieren heute über den antrag der
cdu csu fraktion für eine wehrhafte
demokratie gegenüber jeglicher art von
extremismus und als ich diesen titel
gelesen habe da dachte ich mir ganz
spontan
interessant relevant wichtig
und dann hat sich in meinem hinterkopf
plötzlich ein paar fragen haben sie ein
paar fragen eingestellt und die
wichtigste frage die sich mir gestellt
hat waren ist es nicht für alle
demokratinnen und demokraten eine
selbstverständlichkeit für diese unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
einzutreten sie zu verteidigen gegen
jede und jeden der diese grundordnung in
frage stellt gegen jegliche form der
gewalt gegen jede form des extremismus
ja meine damen und herren das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit und gerade für
diese regierung und die sie tragenden
koalitionsparteien
der neue bericht des bka zeit dass die
zahl der politisch motivierten
gewalttaten insbesondere in den letzten
beiden jahren gestiegen ist das gilt
auch für die gesamtzahl der politisch
motivierten straftaten eine solche
entwicklung dürfen wir nicht hindern
diese zahlen sind nämlich nicht nur
daten sie bedeuten mehr menschen sind
opfer politisch motivierter taten
geworden ihnen muss unsere solidarität
gelten
alle formen des extremismus
es entschieden entgegengetreten werden
diese das ist aber nicht bei maßnahmen
zur bekämpfung von symptomen enden
vielmehr müssen wir auch die ursachen
für extremistische orientierungen
angehen es muss gelingen die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
bei den menschen zu verankern das
geplante demokratie fördern gesetzt das
auch schon angesprochen wurde wird ein
wichtiger schritt sein zur erreichung
dieses ziels und dieser schritt ist
notwendig als wissenschaftspolitiker der
auf drei jahrzehnte praktische erfahrung
im bildungswesen zurückblicken kann weiß
ich um die bedeutung von forschung und
bildung für gesellschaftliche
entwicklungen
politische bildung kann in allen
lebensphasen dazu beitragen die idee
einer offenen gesellschaft zu verstehen
und daran akzeptanz bei den menschen zu
steigern
freiheit und demokratie sind kann ich
selbstverständlichkeiten wir müssen ihre
grundlagen verstehen wir müssen ihre
vorteile kennen wir müssen für sie
kämpfen und bildung kann menschen dazu
befähigen
eskil
es gilt mehr in forschung ihre soziale
zusammenhänge krisensicherheit und
resilienz gegenüber extremistischen
entwicklungen zu investieren
eine wissenschaftlich fundierte analyse
bereitet die grundlage für ein
effektives
politisches handeln es gilt zb zu
verstehen warum sich menschen aus der
gesellschaftlichen mitte während der
korona pandemie radikalisiert haben und
ob sich daraus eine dauerhafte
herausforderung für den zusammenhalt für
unsere gesellschaft und das bekenntnis
zu freiheit und demokratie ergibt
für die koalition geht es nicht darum
nur symptome des extremismus zu
bekämpfen
wir müssen auch die potenziale für einen
weiteren anstieg der zahl extremistisch
denkender und handelnder personen
reduzieren wir müssen die grundlagen
schaffen
wir müssen die grundlagen schaffen dass
extremismus aus unserer gesellschaft
endlich verschwindet und keine weiteren
nährboden in der zukunft halte und dass
mein samen hahn schließt natürlich auch
ein dass jegliches staatliche handeln
dass zum beispiel die grundrechte zur
bekämpfung des extremismus einschränkt
genau auf seine verfassungskonformität
überprüft werden müssen
und lassen sie nicht zum schluss
folgendes betonen bei der bekämpfung des
extremismus in rechtsstaatlichkeit und
faktenbasierte entscheidungen grundlage
für erfolg und akzeptanz der maßnahmen
lassen sie uns deshalb bietet den weg
nicht sorry nicht den weg der angst
sondern ein weg der vernunft gehen
vielen dank
stefan seite aus der fdp fraktion war
der dritte plätze redner in einer
debatte geführt wird auf der grundlage
eines antrags der cdu csu fraktion zum
thema wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber
extremismus und jetzt kommt alexander
hoffmann aus der unionsfraktion der
schon mal eine minute abgezogen bekommen
hat weil seine vorrednerin aus der
unionsfraktion die zeit überzogen hat
und da ist es zwar slv 20 am
freitagmorgen aber bei solchen themen
bei solchen dingen hat
bundestags-vizepräsident kubicki jetzt
schon schlechte laune also eine minute
weniger für alexander hoffmann
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren zuschauer ich
möchte zunächst mal eine vorbemerkung
platzieren weil ich will ihnen schon
sagen dass mich die heftigkeit der
debatte zum einen überrascht und zum
anderen auch bewegt und da will ich
liebe frau kollegin mir alles schon auch
mal in ihre richtung etwas persönliches
formulieren wissen sie es ist eigentlich
schon fast mehr als schlechter stil
wenn sie in dem rahmen dieser debatte
den eindruck erwecken und sie haben
sogar ausdrücklich gesagt also die union
trage die verantwortung für dieses
attentat am breitscheidplatz das war ja
nein an ein relatives ist nicht
relativieren es ist nicht das war das
war die botschaft
und da muss man der vollständigkeit
halber schon einmal dazu sagen der
umstand dass sich der attentäter vom
breitscheidplatz unter dem schirm durchs
gesamte bundesgebiet hat unbehelligt
bewegen können hin zusammen mit einem
sicherheitspolitischen saustall der in
berlin fabriziert worden ist und in
nordrhein-westfalen fabriziert worden
ist und dort haben sie die verantwortung
getragen herr kollege logan inzwischen
keine gülle im dialekt ja herr präsident
selbst bringt mir eine minute zurück
also er hofft man dass was sie mir
gerade vorgeworfen haben das weiß ich
erst mal aufs entschiedenste zurück und
wenn sie mich schon zitieren dann bitte
ich doch darum dass sie mich bitte auch
richtig zitieren ich habe eine reihe von
rechtsextremistischen anschlägen
aufgezählt ich habe auch den anschlag
auf dem breitscheidplatz aufgezählt und
ich habe dabei gesagt dass all diese
ereignisse in eine zeit fielen in denen
die union hier verantwortung getragen
hat und das ist ja wohl unbestreitbar
hoffmann
wie sie sich jetzt hier hinstellen
können und das was ich gesagt habe so
verdrehen können dass ich ihnen
angeblich vorgeworfen habe dass sie von
der union persönlich für diese attentate
verantwortlich sind das ist einfach
ungeheuerlich und das weiss ich aufs
schärfste zurück hoffnung
wir befinden uns hier in einer
politischen auseinandersetzung und ich
hoffe doch sehr dass wir das auch
weiterhin gemeinsam tun können in der
wir darum ringen was denn die beste
sicherheitspolitik hier für unser land
ist und da muss ich noch einmal
eindringlich an sie appellieren dass sie
sich dann auch bitte zu der
verantwortung die sie die letzten 16
jahre hier in diesem haus und dem
bundesinnenministerium getragen haben
auch bekennen herzlichen dank
frau können gehen wir halt schauen sie
das ganze haus ist ja nun mal zeuge
dessen gewesen was sie hier gesagt habe
und jetzt versuchen sie es jetzt
versuchen sie es zum einen relativ zu
relativieren und zum anderen ist es so
warum stellen sie denn genau diesen
zusammenhang her und im übrigen haben
sich sehr viel unmittelbarer formuliert
als es jetzt als es jetzt gerade
formuliert haben ich kann mir vorstellen
ich kann mir vorstellen dass ihnen das
echo jetzt weh getan hat aber wenn sie
sich in ihrer rede wenn sie sich in
ihrer rede mit diesem zusammenhang hier
aufs parkett begeben dann müssen sie
genau mit dem echo reden ich will herr
präsident fortfahren nämlich immer noch
bezüglich der frage der heftigkeit der
debatte warum ist denn die debatte ist
so heftig die union formuliert einen
antrag deshalb verständlichkeit und wir
haben eigentlich damit gerechnet dass
sich die ampel ganz locker hinter diesem
antrag wird versammeln können das ganz
rechts und ganz links probleme damit hat
das war uns klar aber sie verfallen dann
immer in bestimmte mechanismen die
am schluss die diskussion um die details
und ums konkrete erschweren die zwei
mechanismen die geht immer in die
richtung jeder der
wegschaut beziehungsweise jeder der sich
traut richtung linksextremismus fragen
zu formulieren da kann ja schon kein
aufrechter antifaschisten und der zweite
mechanismus gehen sie an den tag legen
ist das dann jeder der über andere
extremismus arten in diesem haus reden
will dass der ja dann gleich den
rechtsextremismus relativiert und
ausdrücklich das tun wir nicht in
unserem antrag wir sind bei ihnen wir
sind bei ihnen
der rechtsextremismus ist für unsere
demokratie die größte gefahr in diesem
land wir unterstützen ihren
zehn-punkte-plan aber wir erlauben uns
den hinweis dass eben genau dieser
ausbaufähig ist weil wir sagen wenn ich
extremismus
effizient bekämpfen will da schauen sie
da geht es wieder los wenn ich
extremismus effizient bekämpfen will
dann brauche ich an den breiten blick
und ich brauche einen gut gefüllten
wirksamen instrumentenkasten mit dem
breiten blick meinen wir den 360 grad
blick ich muss neben dem
rechtsextremismus den linksextremismus
im blick haben den islamistischen
extremismus und den antisemitismus und
wenn ich dann über den zweiten großen
baustein rehman rede nämlich den gut
bestückten instrumentenkasten
dann wissen sie dass immer weg mit dem
hinweis auf bürgerrechte und erwecken
hier immer den eindruck dass die union
liederlich mit bürgerrechten umgehen
wird auch das ist doch nicht richtig wo
ist denn eigentlich
ihr konkretes gegenargument sie alle
wissen dass wir sehr wohl
grundrechtskonforme
maßnahmen zur aufdeckung von
finanzströmen und zur bekämpfung
politischen islamismus auf den weg
bringen könnte kein argument von ihnen
sie wissen genau dass wir
grundrechtskonforme
effektive maßnahmen zur besseren
aufklärung in der linksextremen szene
auf den weg bringen könnten wo ist denn
ihr konkretes gegenargument und sie
wissen sehr wohl dass wir auch
grundgesetzkonform staatliche
fördergelder davon abhängig machen
können dass eine organisation die diese
bekommt unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung auch lebt
dazu sagen sie konkret nicht sondern es
gibt immer nur den pauschalen hinweis
auf bürgerrechte und da sagen wir ihnen
das ist uns zu wenig deshalb stellen wir
diesen antrag und darüber werden wir
natürlich in der ausschussberatung noch
diskutieren danke für die aufmerksamkeit
alexander hoffmann war das aus der
unionsfraktion hat zu beginn seiner rede
sprache und ton fand in dieser debatte
beklagt hat aber auch von einem ich
zitiere saustall in berlin und
düsseldorf gesprochen und dabei auf die
sozialdemokraten verwiesen jetzt ist ein
sozialdemokrat am pult helgeland
er auf man ihre wollte gerade gegenüber
der kollegin die halle zwar zutiefst
schäbig und unredlich das muss ich mal
festhalten
sie wird wie das protokoll zeigen wird
sie war zudem unwahr und es war die
klassische figur eines bebauten und
eines ablenkungsmanövers von ihren
eigenen defiziten dem eigenen scheitern
und das wörther weise haben sie auch den
beweis geführt dass genau das was wir
die ganze zeit sagen der fall ist
nämlich dieser antrag ist nichts
substanziell aber ist ein rein
parteitaktisches manöver nichts anderes
sie drehen ja darin von wehrhafte
demokratie
ich vermisse nur irgendwelche ausführung
zu konzepten zu wehrhafte demokratie in
diesem text
sie
werden sicher ja miterlebt haben auch
aus der pmk aus der statistik zu
politisch motivierter kriminalität was
für eine gewaltige zahl von taten die im
bereich nicht zuzuordnen haben im
zusammenhang mit querdenken krone etc
was für eine unterminierung der
demokratie ich empfehle ihnen daher
dringlich lesen sie einfach mal ein
kurzes interview zb von kollegen coole
da ist in fünf teilen mehr inhalt als in
ihrem gesamten antrag das wären weit
stattdessen
stattdessen führen sie hier dieses vor
und sie zeigen eine reihe von
lehrstellen denn einen konkreten
aktionsplan linksextremismus mit seinen
motiven erkenne ich nicht ebenso wenig
bei der frage des umgangs mit islamismus
irgendwelche innovationen sind
fehlanzeige es ist nur ein sammelsurium
altbekannte motive und forderung ist es
im grunde ein folkloristischer antrag
mit 0 gehalt und der informationswert
ist nicht darin was er sagt sondern was
er nicht sagt sie ich sagen ja in ihrem
titel
wehrhafte demokratie und gegenüber
jeglicher art von extremismus
selbstverständlich kann keiner was dazu
sagen denkt man erst aber es gibt ja
auch so was wie regeln und prinzipien
von sprache semantik pragmatik und die
würden ihnen dann ganz einfach erläutern
dass das eine präsentation ist und die
preise position ist die innenministerin
kümmert sich nicht um alle formen von
extremismus und das ist die frechheit
und die unanständigkeit ihres antrages
unter steckt darin
und jetzt werden sie wieder sagen der
wind kommt mit sprachlichen ausführung
und herr de vries meldet sich
wahrscheinlich wieder wie beim letzten
mal das sei philosophie und
sinnlosigkeit nur wenn's wie sie die art
der analyse die wir betreiben das fragen
nach gründen und die entlarven ihrer
parteitaktische manöver philosophie ist
dann sagt das nichts über ein
philosophie überschuss bei uns aber über
ein eklatantes philosophie defizit bei
ihnen und philosophie bedeutet ja auch
griechische freundschaft zur weisheit
weisheit war aber bei diesem antrag
nicht federführend
wir müssen ja des weiteren auch
feststellen und das widerspricht auch
dem prinzip von weisheit dass herr
seehofer
innenminister nicht nur am ende seiner
amtszeit vehement für ein thema
demokratie fördergesetz geworben hat
sondern auch endlich richtigerweise ganz
klar bekannte dass die größte gefahr in
diesem land der rechtsextremismus ist
somit hat er zwei aufträge erteilt
demokratie fördergesetz und bekämpfung
von rechtsextremismus
frau feser hat diese aufträge intensiv
angegriffen das heißt sie sollten sie
nicht kritisieren sie müssten ein dankes
antrag schreiben dass sie das umsetzt
was ihr eigener minister versprochen hat
stattdessen
stattdessen kommen sie mit
extremismusklausel reloaded demokratie
treueerklärung und es kann mich nicht
wirklich überzeugen wenn sie doch
wirklich eine wehrhafte demokratie
wollen und wenn sie das unterstelle ich
in demokratie fördern wollen dass sie
dann ein angriff fahren gegen die
demokratie verteidigen und fördern mit
angriffen auf demokratie vorderen
fördert man logischerweise nicht die
demokratie und stellen sich damals die
situation vor von verein institution in
landstrichen in denen die alv die
dominant ist die da schafften gegen
querdenker gegen querulanten der
unmenschlichkeit gegen selbst verwalter
und so weiter stellen sie sich mal die
situation vollauf sie lagen diese in
einem raum und dann legen sie diesen
antrag vor was sie sagen müssten es wir
bekräftigen euer tun wir unterstützen
ist wir verstetigen die forderung
stattdessen ist ihre message wir
vertrauen euch nicht ihr seid ja latent
linksextrem und ihr steht nicht auf der
bundesverfassung ich finde das ist
absolut unanständig auch gegenüber
diesen vorkämpfe uns die demokratie
deshalb brauchen wir für demokratie
förderung in der tat ein demokratie
fördergesetz und sie sollten die ersten
die sich dafür einsetzen das ist sowieso
ein täuschungsmanöver warum erwecken sie
den eindruck
aktivistischer einsatz sie wie
gesellschaftliche einsatz für demokratie
gegen rechtsextremismus wäre verdächtigt
des linksextremismus ist doch absurd
demokratie förderung ist doch links noch
rechts weder liberal noch konservativ
das sollte uns doch alle ein sie sollten
als erste auch als konservativer
aufstehen und sagen wir wollen ein
funktionierendes demokratie fördergesetz
und das zweite und letzte
sie können der richtigerweise ein
aktionsprogramm und sonstwas gegen
islamismus fordern aber was ist denn mit
den ganz vielen normalen muslimischen
menschen oder solche die so gelesen
werden wahrgenommen werden die lesen im
landtag nichts über antimuslimischer
rassismus nicht über ihre
alltagserfahrungen täglich diskriminiert
zu werden aber sie müssen sich mit dem
vorwurf des islamismus ausgesetzt
beschluss nichts dagegen wenn sie
konzeptuell erfolgreich gegen islamismus
arbeiten sollen dann dürfen sie nicht
über antimuslimischen rassismus und
formen von fremdenfeindlichkeit und
integrationsfeindlich und ähnlicher
stigmatisierung schweigen kollegen sie
wirklich islamismus bekämpfen sollen
dann kämpfen sie auch gegen rassismus
lernen sie daraus vielen dank
soweit der demokratiepolitische sprecher
der spd-fraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag helden und wind und das war
dann für heute die beratung zu diesem
antrag der unionsfraktion für eine
wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber jeglicher
art von extremismus
der antrag wird jetzt an die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen und
wir kommen damit zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
in diesem wird über das verbot der
information für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch
diskutiert grund ist es gibt ein
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung die
den entsprechenden paragrafen 219
aufheben möchte
dass dieser paragraf ist schon seit
längerem ja in der diskussion da geht es
darum dass vorher es keine so genannte
werbung für schwangerschafts abbrüche
geben durfte das bedeutete dass ärzte
zum beispiel auf ihrer website schreiben
durften dass die schwangerschafts
abbrüche durch abbrüche durchführen die
union hat dann mit der spd in der großen
koalition lange darüber diskutiert damit
war man aber letztendlich mit dem
konsens der dann geschaffen wurde auch
nicht zufrieden und marco buschmann
bundesjustizminister spricht jetzt dazu
vor ziemlich genau 30 jahren im frühling
1992 arbeiteten abgeordnete der spd
fraktion und abgeordnete der fdp
fraktion an einem gruppenantrag dieser
gruppen antrag hatte die veränderung des
damaligen paragrafen 218 des
strafgesetzbuches zum gegenstand und er
enthielt bereits alle wesentlichen
eckpunkte der noch heute geltenden
beratungslösungen er setzte sich durch
in einem verfahren von insgesamt sieben
anträgen und wenige zeit später ist
dieses papier in einen gesetzentwurf
überführt worden der dann auch die
mehrheit im haus fand und das ist bis
heute
das geltende recht warum erwähne ich das
hier immer wieder wird falsch behauptet
die entscheidung die wir heute treffen
über 219 a seine respektlosigkeit oder
gar unterhöhlung des lebensschutz
konzeptes von 218 und dazu möchte ich
zwei dinge sagen uns muss niemand den
respekt vor diesem historischen
kompromiss lehrern es waren unsere
politischen vorgänger die ihn
geschmiedet und vorbereitet haben
zweitens es
ist eine juristische eine politische und
eine historische wahrheit dass paragraph
218 des strafgesetzbuches und parat 219
nichts aber auch gar nichts miteinander
zu tun haben das ist keine
beeinträchtigung des lebens
schutzkonzept ich bitte diese wahrheit
zu akzeptieren
das worum es
sollte eigentlich geht kann man an der
lebenswirklichkeit erkennen und stellen
sie sich dazu bitte eine junge frau vor
die spanner ist die in erwägung zieht
diese schwangerschaft zu unterbrechen
das stellen sich sehr schwierige fragen
und es gibt im regelfall ein großes
bedürfnis nach orientierung nach
informationen und in unserer digitalen
wirklichkeit führt dieses bedürfnis doch
natürlich in sehr vielen fällen ins
internet weil dort eine gefühlte
anonymität und privatheit herrscht und
deshalb die schwelle dort nach
informationen zu suchen doch erst mal
niedriger ist als ich einem dritten
vielleicht einem fremden menschen
anzuvertrauen das ist die wirklich das
ist die lebenswirklichkeit und die
rechtslage dort die sieht heute wie
folgt aus im internet erlauben wir jedem
verschwörungstheoretiker jeder fake news
schneider jeden uns über
schwangerschafts abbrüche zu verbreiten
aber qualifizierte ärztinnen und ärzte
als hüter der wissenschaft der fakten
der sachlichkeit und der aufklärung dem
verbieten wir sachliche informationen
bereitzustellen das ist doch absurd ein
anachronismus seine um gerechtigkeit und
es ist die konsequenz aus 219 und
deshalb schaffen wir ihn ab meine damen
und herren
drei sorten
möchte ich an dieser stelle nehmen weil
das ja wirklich eine ernsthafte debatte
ist die wir führen müssen die erste
sorge möchte ich noch mal sagen diese
rechtsänderung hat keine auswirkungen
auf das leben schutzkonzept von
paragraph 218 des strafgesetzbuches
zweitens die gefahr abstoßender
irreführender werbung besteht nicht denn
wir haben in unserem entwurf
das heilmittelwerbegesetz so erweitert
dass es auch schwangerschafts abbrüche
die nicht medizinisch indiziert sind mit
umfasst das heißt die strengen regeln
des heindl werbe gesetzes gelten auch
hier und das berufsrecht der ärztin und
ärzte gebietet ohnehin nur sachlich zu
informieren und keine reißerische
werbung
und eine dritte sorge möchte ich nehmen
die auch immer wieder geäußert wird geht
es darum oder führte dazu dass ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch dadurch
wahrscheinlicher wird aber darum geht es
gar nicht wir wollen dass eine frau wenn
sie es möchte
informierter entscheiden kann und das
sollte in einer aufgeklärten
gesellschaft eine selbstverständlichkeit
sein meine damen
letzten gedanken möchte ich sagen weil
wir in unseren gesetzentwurf auch für
die wenigen aber schwerwiegenden fälle
wo es schon zu einer verurteilung kam
eine rehabilitierung lösung aufgenommen
haben die entscheidung haben wir uns
nicht leicht gemacht denn das ist immer
ein eingriff in die gewaltenteilung aber
es geht hier um wenige fälle und das ist
glaube ich deshalb richtig und wichtig
weil wir die verurteilten ärzte und
ärzte nichts auf dem gnadenweg beim
bundespräsident zwingen wollen sie
sollten nicht um gnade bitten müssen
sondern wir sollten das problem aus der
welt schaffen wir hätten es schon im
letzten bundestag tun können der
gesetzgeber hätte schon handelt die
mehrheits leute die die alte koalition
nicht hatte hat dazu jetzt die
fortschritts koalition herzlichen dank
eurer hilfe
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann hat
hier den gesetzentwurf verteidigt
damit frauen die sich zu einem
schwangerschaftsabbruch entscheiden
möchten sich oder das überlegen sich
besser informieren können die
unionsfraktion hat einen antrag
eingereicht in dem sie fordert den
schutz des ungeborenen kindes
beizubehalten sondern sie es und für die
unionsfraktion spricht jetzt nina wagen
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen kollegen herr minister
auch wenn sich bemüht haben hier ein
anderes bild abzugeben es ist schon
erstaunlich und macht mich auch
sprachlos ein stück weit mit wie wenig
sensibilität sie an das thema herangehen
und in den letzten tagen konnte man
einiges einige äußerungen von ihnen dazu
auch lesen sie sprechen von
befreiungsschlag mit groß auf der
webseite der fdp angekündigt ein
befreiungsschlag für die frau und damit
zeichnet sie ein völlig falsches bild
der derzeitigen lage und das für mich
schon verantwortungslos
in deutschland sichert das geltende
recht den zugang zu einem medizinisch
korrekten schwangerschaftsabbruch
innerhalb von zwölf wochen nach der
zeugung allein aufgrund der entscheidung
der schwangeren ohne jedes
strafrechtliche risiko unabhängig von
der finanziellen situation und circa
100.000 frauen machen davon jedes jahr
gebraucht keine einzige hat ein
strafrechtliches risiko einzige
voraussetzung ist eine beratung dort
wird umfassend über hilfen und ansprüche
informiert aber eben auch über das
lebensrecht des kindes anschließend
liegt die entscheidung allein bei der
frau diese regelung meine damen und
herren stellen wir nicht infrage aber
aber wir sind auch klar der meinung das
ist keine zusätzliche werbung braucht
bei ihrem gesetzentwurf geht es
keineswegs nur um information auf den
praxis webseiten auf die die schwanger
nur stößt wenn sie gezielt danach sucht
da sind ihre beispiele liebe kollegen
der ampel fraktionen und die
gesetzesbegründung schlicht nicht
ehrlich wenn sie nur das wollen dann
legen sie doch
dann legen sie doch auch einen
gesetzentwurf vor der auch nur das
ermöglicht die geplante streichung von
219 ermöglicht anders als sie heute
wieder behaupten viel mehr zum beispiel
werbung in den sozialen medien anzeigen
und plakate sie richten sich nicht
reißerisch aber aktiv an die zielgruppe
und das sehen wir genau in ländern ohne
werbeverbot werben kliniken bei dem der
abbruch am günstigsten oder am
schnellsten geht und bei wem die
atmosphäre am freundlichsten ist und das
ist dass unsere auffassung mit dem
verfassungsrechtlichen schutz des
ungeborenen unvereinbar
ein schwangerschaftsabbruch ist keine
normale ärztliche heilbehandlung er
beendet einmaliges individuelles
menschliches leben und es darf nicht
verharmlost werden und auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht fordert dass
das gespür für das lebensrecht des
kindes im allgemeinen bewusstsein
erhalten bleiben muss werbung ist mit
den grundrechten und mit der würde des
ungeborenen nicht vereinbar werte
kollegen der regierungsfraktionen
billigen nicht auseinander beim blick
auf die schwangere frau jeder kann
nachempfinden dass eine ungewollte
schwangerschaft einen massiven konflikt
auslösen kann in einer solchen situation
ist es absolut selbstverständlich dass
sie sich als erstes im netz informiert
meine these ist allerdings dass sie jede
medizinische information über die
verschiedenen varianten von
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen und auch die
liste der bundesärztekammer mit den
praxen und kliniken mit wenigen klicks
im netz findet und wo es ihnen
eigentlich da genau fehlt sagen sie auch
nicht klar und es gibt natürlich jede
möglichkeit sich unmittelbar beim arzt
über alle details zu informieren indem
man zb dort anruft sie tun so als gäbe
es da irgend ein tabu und es ist doch
unsinn außerhalb von wertung gibt es
keinerlei limit bei der information und
trotzdem sind wir in unserem eigenen
antrag auch offen dafür den umfang der
sachlichen informationen auf der
webseite der ärzte zu erweitern wo wir
auseinander lägen werte kollegen der
ampel ist beim blick auf das ungeborene
und dass dieser wichtige aspekt in ihrer
argumentation kaum eine rolle spielt ist
für mich unfassbar
sie weichen dieser frage auch heute in
den reden und anträgen aus das kind
kommt darin nicht vor oder sie sprechen
bloß von schwangerschafts gewebe aber
sagen wir doch mal wie es ist von anfang
an sind alle genetischen anlagen
festgelegt von anfang an gibt es eine
bruchlose kontinuierliche entwicklung
und das bundesverfassungsgericht hat es
auf die formel gebracht das ungeborene
entwickelt sich von anfang an als mensch
und nicht erst zum menschen und daraus
folgen grundrechte des ungeborenen und
diese müssen auch bei der wahrung der
alleinige entscheidung der frau dann
natürlich berücksichtigt werden es
erfordert ein schutzkonzept zugunsten
des kindes mit der beratung und mit dem
verbot von werbung und noch kurz ein
paar gedanken zur situation der ärzte
drei wichtige punkte erstens viele ärzte
führen aus gewissensgründen keine
abbrüche durch das spiel 219 a überhaupt
keine rolle zweitens es ist klar und
ohne jeden graubereich geregelt welche
informationen auf den webseiten der
ärzte zulässig sind unklar ist die
regelung bisher nicht viel mehr wird sie
erst durch den gesetzentwurf unklar und
drittens eine aktive ansprache von
patientinnen ist auch heute schon
möglich meine damen und herren kurzum
wir sind bereit für gezielte
verbesserung eine streichung von 219 a
lehnen wir aber ab da
die rede von innen erwarten war dass aus
der unionsfraktion ich habe es eben
schon angedeutet ist gab in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode in der
großen koalition einen minimalkonsens
dass man gesagt hat man kann zwar als
arzt informieren aber nicht über das wie
sondern dass man einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch anbietet für die
spd-fraktion spricht jetzt kam
entwickeln der demokratischen parteien
sehr geehrte damen und herren gerade bin
ich versucht kurz innezuhalten auf zu
schauen und diese situation zu genießen
denn dies ist der moment für den so
viele frauen jahrzehntelang auf die
straße gegangen sind dieses der moment
für den so viele ärztinnen und ärzte
gekämpft haben dies ist der moment in
dem wir endlich in das parlamentarische
verfahren zur streichung von 219 aus dem
strafgesetzbuch eintreten dies ist der
moment der uns frauen ein stück weit die
hoheit über ihr würde ihre körper
zurückgeben wird es ist ein schöner
moment
alle
die bis jetzt nicht nachvollziehen
können warum dies ein schöner moment ist
dem sei folgendes gesagt
219 a trat am 26
mai 1933 in kraft und ist ein paragraf
des ns unrechts regimes
[Applaus]
es ist eine regelung die vorgeschoben
nach außen zum ziel hatte dafür zu
sorgen dass schwangerschafts abbrüche
nicht verharmlost und kommerzialisiert
werden
tatsächlich ist diese regelung aber eine
manifestation des patriarchalen und
frauenfeindlichen naziregimes
tatsächlich hatte diese regelung zum
ziel
frauen durch den mangel an informationen
dazu zu bringen nicht abzurechnen und es
ihnen deutlich zu erschweren
219 ist damit ein gutes beispiel dafür
dass überall dort wo rechte parteien an
der macht sind frauenrechte
eingeschränkt werden
das ist erschreckend
das ist 89 jahre gedauert hat bis wir
diesen missstand beheben können der
schon längst ist klar dass 219 nur zu
drei dingen führt erstens die
kriminalisierung von ärztinnen und
ärzten die frauen in notsituationen
beistehen zweitens dass die medizinische
versorgungslage in deutschland für
frauen sehr sehr schlecht geworden ist
und drittens dass frauen aufgrund des
mangels an informationen oder über den
abbruch keine freie und differenzierte
entscheidung treffen können
denn bei 219 euro geht es eben nicht um
werbung sowie das leider immer wieder
von der union suggeriert wird sondern um
informationen und nein das ist auch kein
kleiner sondern ein großer unterschied
wir frauen werden endlich zugang zu
allen informationen haben die wir
benötigen um eine entscheidung fällen zu
können wer führt abbrüche durch und
welche methoden sind dabei möglich das
sind die relevanten fragen die ich als
frau in einer solchen situation
beantwortet haben möchte und endlich
dürfen wir das auch ärztinnen und ärzte
sagen und nicht irgendwelche
youtube-star für die diese regelung
nämlich nicht gilt
wer glaubt
wer glaubt dass die streichung von 219
dazu führen wird dass ärztinnen auf
einmal zu reißerischer werbung in bezug
auf schwangerschafts abbrüche neigen
werden der kennt sich außerhalb des
strafgesetzbuches meiner meinung nach
nicht gut aus nicht nur das gesetz gegen
den unlauteren wettbewerb steht
reißerischer werbung in diesem bereich
entgegen auch die berufsordnungen der
landesärztekammern
um aber trotz
das ist die rechtliche situation liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen um aber
trotzdem jeden rechtlichen zweifel
auszuräumen werden wir mit diesem
gesetzesentwurf auch das
heilmittelwerbegesetz anpassen das hat
der minister schon gesagt und den
anwendungsbereich auch schwangerschafts
abbrüche ausweiten dieser
gesetzesentwurf ist daher über jeden
zweifel erhaben
und dieser in den raum gestellte vorwurf
gegenüber den ärztinnen und ärzten die
in deutschland abbrüche durchführen ist
nicht nur absurd sondern meiner meinung
nach auch respektlos
daher möchte ich
daher möchte ich meine redezeit auch
nutzen um hier diesen ärztinnen und
ärzten danke zu sagen danke dass ihr uns
frauen die auf eure hilfe angewiesen
sind bei steht stellvertretend dafür
danke christina handle die durch ihre
prozesse vor gericht
das problem noch mal deutlicher in die
öffentlichkeit getragen hat danke an dr
bettina graber und dr verena beyer aus
berlin die klar benannt haben dass der
kampf gegen 219 a ein feministischer
kampf ist danke
danke an doktor detlef michel märsche
der sich standhaft geweigert hat die
sachlichen informationen auf seiner
website runterzunehmen und danke an
doktor friedrich der trotz seiner 75
jahre nicht mit seiner arbeit aufhört
weil sonst ein drittel der frauen in
bayern wie ein abbruch vornehmen wollen
nicht mehr versorgt werden danke dafür
es ist folgerichtig dass das unrecht das
ihnen durch die kriminalisierung
zugefügt worden ist wiedergutgemacht
werden muss es ist folgerichtig das
würde ich den heute vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf alle urteile die auf
grundlage von 219 gefällt worden sind
aufheben werden es ist folgerichtig zu
sagen in dem zur verfügung stellen von
informationen kann kein unrecht liegen
ist tut uns leid
heute
kommen sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
unionsfraktion nein danke
weil ich komme mir zu meinem selbst
letzten versetzen und die sind mir sehr
wichtig heute ist ein guter tag das ist
ein schöner moment gewöhnen sie sich
daran wir gehen vorwärts niemals zurück
vielen dank
carmen wegge hat das hearing schönen tag
genannt heute wird allerdings noch nicht
über diesen gesetzentwurf abgestimmt
sondern wird nach dieser ersten lesung
in die entsprechenden ausschüsse
überwiesen und kommt dann noch mal ins
plenum und dann wird hier darüber
diskutiert nächster redner in dieser
debatte ist nun thomas seitz
rechtspolitische spahni es gibt erst
eine kurzintervention aus den seiten der
unionsfraktion
es kommt immer nur vernünftiges von mir
den ich noch frau kollegin ich habe eine
anmerkung ich hatte eigentlich eine
frage gehabt aber das kann man auch
denke ich in diese kurzintervention
klären ich habe mir noch mal angeschaut
ich war bis zum einzug in den deutschen
bundestag
zirka zwei jahrzehnte strafrichter und
was wir in der 18 wahlperiode was der
deutsche bundestag in der 18 wahlperiode
hier beschlossen hat und da ging es um
dieses strafrechtliche
rehabilitierungsgesetz wegen der
diskriminierenden verurteilungen
homosexueller straftäter in diesem
zusammenhang hat man auch beschlossen
dass diese urteile aufzuheben sind um
diese diskriminierenden diskriminieren
entscheidungen zu beseitigen dass das
aus dem bundeszentralregister soweit
noch eingetragen getilgt wird weil das
war die grundlage des ganzen mann wie es
schon betont habe gesagt hat das war
schreiendes unrecht
sind sie der meinung dass die
verurteilung die kollegen oder
kolleginnen von mir in den letzten
jahren das waren ja nur wenige wegen
verstoßes gegen zwei 19 a stgb gemacht
haben schreiendes unrecht dargestellt
werden mit dem der deutsche rechtsstaat
nicht leben kann und weshalb ist diese
urteile aufzuheben sind der kollege
buschmann hat von der durchbrechung der
gewaltenteilung der jüngst in dieser
verfassung gesprochen sind sie der
meinung dass an dieser stelle die
gewaltenteilung durchbrochen werden muss
frau klinger sie können antworten
ja
ja ich sage es nochmal kurz ich habe das
eigentlich meine rede beantwortet aber
ja wir gehen davon aus dass uns
schreiendes unrecht ist weil es geht
hier um informationen und wer immer
information teilt und deswegen bestraft
wird das ist eine politische
entscheidung dass wir das als so groß
ist um recht einordnen und es ist eine
richtige
sobald die kurzintervention von axel
müller und die wiederum von karmann
becker und jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten
redner hier in der debatte thomas seitz
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren kommen wir
zurück zur sachlichkeit
der vorgelegte gesetzentwurf redet von
reproduktiver selbstbestimmung als
euphemismus für die tötung ungeborener
kinder
wahrheitswidrig behauptet dass es
rechtsunsicherheit bei der zulässigkeit
öffentlicher
informationen über abtreibungen gebe
dabei ist eindeutig dass ärzte
öffentlich auch jetzt schon darüber
informieren dürfen ob sie abtreibungen
nur dürfen durch durchführen nur nicht
wie das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
unverrückbare grenzen gezogen zitat
rechtlicher schutz gebührt dem
ungeborenen auch gegenüber seiner mutter
nun weiter ein solcher schutz ist nur
möglich wenn der gesetzgeber ihr einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch grundsätzlich
verbietet und ihr damit die
grundsätzliche rechtspflicht auferlegt
das kind auszutragen
zur erfüllung dieser schutzpflicht
musterstaat ausreichende maßnahmen
ergreifen um einen angemessenen und
wirksamen schutz zu erreichen dies ist
der grundsatz des unter maß verbots
wesentlich für das schutzkonzept ist die
trennung zwischen beratung und der
durchführung der abtreibung öffentliche
informationen über abtreibung durch
ärzte die diese selbst durchführen sind
mit dem schutzkonzept nicht vereinbar
und genau deshalb verboten es stimmt
einfach nicht dass § 209 10 a das
auffinden eines geeigneten arztes
erschwert und die medizinische
versorgung beeinträchtige
denn es dauert keine minute um mit
internet die seite familienplanung der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung zu finden die seite
informiert umfassend egal ob zur
rechtslage beratungsschein oder methoden
der abtreibung und ihre kosten nach
postleitzahlen sortiert sind für das
gesamte bundesgebiet ärzte und kliniken
aufgeführt die abtreibungen anbieten man
findet nicht nur adresse telefon e-mail
und homepage sondern auch angaben zur
angebotenen methode und zu fremdsprachen
egal ob er sich oder swahili in baden
württemberg gibt es ein angebot zur
abtreibung auch in diesen sprachen die
leichte verfügbarkeit der informationen
zeit dass es in wahrheit keinen zu
beseitigenden missstand gibt warum jedes
landen das zeigt ein erbarmungsloser
offenheit der antrag der linken ein
antrag für den ich wirklich dankbar bin
natürlich nicht dankbar für die
ethischen abgründe die sich darin auf
tun aber wohl für seine schonungslose
ehrlichkeit offen wird hier als
regierungsziel gefordert mit der
abschaffung von paragraph 218 abtreibung
bedingungen frei zu erlauben also bis
unmittelbar vor der geburt mehr
perversion des rechts ist kaum
vorstellbar der wille der koalition alle
strafurteile zu § 209 10 a generell
aufzuheben also bewusst auch alle fälle
von grob anstößig oder irreführender
werbung verdeutlicht dass es in wahrheit
auch ihr darum geht das verbot der
abtreibung in frage zu stellen nur sagt
man ist eben nicht so offen wie die
linken das nenne ich salamitaktik eine
abtreibung ist aber keiner maler
medizinischer eingriff sondern sie
beendet vorsätzlich menschliches leben
niemand unterstellt frauen die sich für
eine abtreibung entscheiden es sich
einfach zu machen aber wir als
gesellschaft dürfen eine abtreibung auch
nicht zu einfach machen so sexuellen
freiheit gehören auch sich
eigenverantwortlich vor einer
ungewollten schwangerschaften schützen
und der zugang zur empfängnisverhütende
mittel ist definitiv heute zu tage keine
hürde mehr in diskussionen mit schülern
war ich zuletzt entsetzt über die
aggression des bewusstseins für recht
und unrecht
für viele ist abtreibung nur
nachgelagerte empfängnisverhütung und
eine selbstverständlichkeit und das auf
die tötung menschlichen lebens niemals
sein da um die 100.000 registrierten
abtreibungen jedes jahr brauchen frauen
mehr unterstützen um damit sie sich für
ihr kind entscheiden es braucht eine
grundgesetzwidrige förderung der
abtreibung sondern eine
willkommenskultur für kinder vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
meine damen und herren sie sehen es wir
zeigen hier auch schon ein bild aus der
ostseeküste in der nähe des weißen
häuser stranz findet ihr das treffen der
außenminister der g 7 staaten statt und
wir erwarten annalena baerbock unsere
aussenministerin dort zu einem statement
zu lange bleiben wir aber natürlich in
der debatte und dort spricht eine
weitere ministerin lisa paus
bundesfamilienministerin
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen wie wir
bürger innen die streichung des
paragrafen 219 a ist längst überfällig
wer anders als die schwangeren sollte
entscheiden ob sie ein kind austragen
möchten oder können wer anders als
frauen sollte darüber entscheiden wann
und in welchen abständen sie kinder
bekommen und wer anders
und wer anders als mediziner innen
sollte diesen frauen bei stehen und sie
über einen abbruch informieren
es geht uns um die mentale es geht um
existenzielle fragen um das
menschenrecht auf reproduktive selbst
recht von frauen über ihren körper zu
entscheiden
und selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist auch das recht
des kindes auf leben ein menschenrecht
spielen wir doch beide rechte nicht
gegeneinander aus alle statistiken
zeigen es ist die gute beratung die
frauen mut macht für ein leben mit einem
kind und nicht die androhung von strafe
und erst recht nicht die aktionen von
abtreibungsgegnern
die schwangere frauen vor
beratungsstellen belästigen und zu
kriminellen erklären
das sogenannte werbeverbot untergräbt
das recht von frauen auf körperliche
selbstbestimmung und ihr recht sich über
abtreibung zu informieren und das ist
schlicht zynisch dass ärztinnen dafür
strafverfolgung fürchten müssen wir
damit ja es ist gut dass ihr ein paar
daten aus den armen auf die
frauen aber unsere ganze gesellschaft
brauchen rechtssichere lösung für alle
lebenswirklichkeiten und das
bundesfamilienministerium ministerin
freue ich mich riesig über den erfolg
der frühen hilfen die bundesstiftung
mutter und kind oder auch unsere
bundesinitiative hilfe und unterstützung
vor ungewollter kinderlosigkeit
reproduktive rechte sind leider nicht
selbstverständlich
sie geraten immer wieder unter druck das
zeigt jetzt auch der entwurf des us
supreme courts und auch in europäischen
nachbarländern deuten sich geschlecht
politische rohbeck sun
der fraktion rechts von uns allen
scheint das zu gefallen gehören radio
hören konnten dieses gesetz und die
debatte heute haben eine wichtige
signalwirkung die bundesregierung diese
bundesregierung steht an der seite der
frauen und zu ihrem recht auf
körperliche selbstbestimmung
und deshalb deshalb wollen wir auch ein
zweiter schritt gehen und die regelungen
für den schwangerschaftsabbruch
außerhalb des stgb treffen um diese
hochkomplexen juristischen fragen zu
klären setzen wir eine kommission zur
reproduktiven selbstbestimmung ein so
wie sich frauen auf medizinische
leistungen verlassen dürfen wenn sie
sich für ein kind entscheiden sollen sie
künftig optische leistung vertrauen
können wenn sie sich gegen ein kind
entscheiden
das war es auch wo es gehört einfach
nicht im strafrecht meine damen und
herren ich bin sicher
gemeinsam mit expertinnen und meinen
kollegen
bundesjustizministerium und vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium werden wir
gute antworten finden ich bitte sie um
ihre unterstützung ganz herzlich
die bundesfrauenministerin lisa paus war
dass die linksfraktion hat hier auch
einen antrag eingereicht in dem sie
fordert im paragrafen 218 zu streichen
da geht es darum dass
schwangerschaftsabbrüche grundsätzlich
verboten sind teilt die reicheneck
spricht jetzt für die linke
nach über 90 jahren wird der nazi § 209
10 a mit dem frauen und ärztinnen
entmündigt und drangsaliert werden weil
endlich der vergangenheit angehören
dafür sorgen wir jetzt
die bezeichnung werbeverbots ist aber
einfach nur widerwärtig untergräbt noch
heute den kampf der frauen für
körperliche selbstbestimmung
denn das ist noch der kern um den es
hier geht es geht nicht um werbung es
geht um neutrale und umfassende
informationen über einen medizinischen
eingriff frau kollegin jeannette
zwischenfrage des kollegen
kriegssituationen
verlängert und auf ihre rede günter
krings aus der unionsfraktion hat eine
zwischenfrage präsenten frau kollegin
ich will nur einen einzigen historisch
sachlichen punkt richtig stellen weil er
mehrfach falsch genannt worden ist sind
sie bereit zur kenntnis zu nehmen dass
der vorgänger paragraf dieses
werbeverbot ist das hier heute
jedenfalls deutlich eingeschränkt werden
soll nicht in der nazi zeit entstanden
ist soll in der weimarer republik an der
vorgänger demokratie die sicherlich
nicht perfekt waren aber demokratisch
parteien gestritten haben auch um solche
themen und dort ist er konzipiert worden
ist in der tat erst noch 233 ins
gesetzblatt gekommen aber konzipiert
worden in der weimarer zeit ein
historisches faktum sind sie bereits das
zur kenntnis zu nehmen
meine kollegin von der spd hat es schon
sehr gut dargestellt wie der kursverlauf
und
sehr interessiert der sie ja auch sehr
interessiert gelauscht habe ich erinnere
mich an ihre zwischenrufe da habe ich
auch noch mal ganz genau dargestellt in
welchem geist dieser artikel entstanden
ist dieser paragraph umgesetzt wurde und
sie können die gern nochmal anhören
aber gut ich mache dann mal weiter weil
wenn nicht dann nämlich höhere liebe cdu
csu oder sind zitate von ihnen man muss
ja nicht jede mode mitmachen und
abtreibungskliniken die haben dann sowie
schönheitsklinik und gerade eben wieder
dann gibt es die zielgruppenspezifische
werbung dann frage ich mich ja welches
raum bilden haben sie eigentlich denken
sie wirklich dass irgendeine frau sagt
mensch das ist ja mal eine spannende
erfahrung so eine abtreibung jetzt mache
ich das oder mensch was für eine schöne
broschüre dann mache ich wohne
abtreibung glauben sie dass frauen so
denken ja ich merke schon alles klar die
merkliche selbst wie absurd das klingt
ja die aktuelle konform ist regierung
der großen koalition ist ein elend und
wenn die cdu/csu dieses elend ins mit
ihrem antrag auch noch festklopfen will
liebe kolleginnen und sage ich mal
stellvertretend für die mehrheit des
hauses und der gesamtgesellschaft
die streichung von 219 a und ja das ist
richtig ist nur der erste schritt den
wir gehen müssen schwangerschafts
abbrüche die auf den wunsch der
schwangeren durchgeführt werden müssen
endlich entkriminalisiert werden auch
das eu-parlament und die
weltgesundheitsorganisation fordern
exakt das deswegen muss auch paragraf
218 endlich weg und deswegen brauchen
wir nicht nur eine kommission die
darüber diskutiert ob 218 feld sondern
wie und wir brauchen diese kommission
sofort doch aktuell steht nicht mal fest
wer darin wie arbeiten soll von der
einrichtung ganz zu schweigen deswegen
fordern wir in unserem antrag auch das
reproduktive gerechtigkeit endlich zum
regierungsstil erklärt wird damit wir
auch endlich vorankommen und mal zum
thema nachgelagerte verhütung wie das
gerade von der afg benannt wurde was ja
ich sag dazu wenig aber stellen sie sich
mal vor wir würden jetzt erwarten dass
jedermann ja keine kinder will eine
vasektomie durchführen lässt das wäre
doch mal was ne scheint aber auch ein
bisschen absurd absolut übergriffig aber
man erwartet ja schließlich von frauen
auch dass die hormone stufen die massive
nebenwirkungen haben man erwartet von
frauen dass sie für die pille danach
eine demütige beratung über sich ergehen
lassen und eigentlich erwartet man
ehrlicherweise von frauen auch dass sie
noch die kondome dabei haben um am ende
mit irgendwie tiefen diskutieren zu
müssen dass sich das ja nicht so toll
anfühlt bedeutet vielleicht auch das
rauchen darf der vielleicht sind dann
dazwischen erlauben sie alles mischen
frau kollegin frau kollegin erlauben sie
eine zwischenfrage von frau von storch
war das sind 1 9 oder nur ein
stoßseufzer
verhütung ist auch schon die komplette
verantwortung der frau wertes forschung
tötungsmethoden für männer kaum gibt und
nach alldem kriminalisieren wir frauen
auch noch und machen ihnen den zugang zu
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen so schwer und
teuer wie möglich frauen mit geld ja die
können zu einer weit entfernten praxis
fahren sich ein hotel erlauben sie
fahren notfalls für eine abtreibung über
die grenze aber stellen sie sich mal vor
200 kilometer anfang und wir verlassen
die aussprache an dieser stelle
umschauen richtung weißen haus
ist und bleibt realität wenn wir nicht
endlich dafür sorgen dass
schwangerschaftsabbrüche
entkriminalisiert werden wenn wir nicht
endlich dafür sorgen dass sie
flächendeckend kostenfrei zur verfügung
steht das ist auch eine soziale frage
und wolf hatten die eigentlich noch die
attraktionen haben die streicher im
parlament bereits 2017 auf den weg
gebracht und stehen weiter seite an
seite mit all jenen die schon
jahrzehntelang für den kampf für sichere
und kostenlose schwangerschafts abbrüche
führen die beleidigt bedroht und
verurteilt wurden und werden ich möchte
jeder einfach die uns hierher gebracht
hat wir werden nicht aufhören jetzt erst
recht und es gibt noch viel zu tun wir
dürfen
die story ist gegenstand bei der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir bringen
einen gesetzentwurf ein der in § 209 10
a strafgesetzbuch
ersatzlos streicht und damit endlich die
sachliche information über
schwangerschafts abbrüche durch
ärztinnen und ärzte
entkriminalisiert
und weil es ungerecht war wie es bisher
lief das sie in der vergangenheit wegen
der informationen über eine medizinische
behandlung bestraft wurden wollen wir
gleichzeitig auch alle urteile seit dem
oktober 2090
1990 aufheben in zukunft können
schwangere also endlich sachliche
informationen über abbrüche auf den
webseiten von ärztinnen und ärzten
finden und ehrlich gesagt dafür wurde es
auch endlich zeit meine damen und herren
soweit also die bundes außenministerin
annalena baerbock und damals sind wir
auch schon wieder zurück in der debatte
sie haben keine rednerin verpasst nur
den anfang von canan bayram von 5 90 die
grünen gehören in ihren reihen
im krankenhaus landen oder im
schlimmsten fall sterben der sicher
versorgung ist lebensschutz meine damen
und herren
und deswegen ist es auch so scheinheilig
wenn die cdu/csu ihren antrag in ihren
antrag schreibt und sie haben es in
ihrer rede ja auch noch peinlicher weise
wiederholt frau kollegin ohne 219 a
könne nicht sichergestellt werden dass
schwangerschaftsabbrüche künftig nicht
kommerzialisiert werden da fraglich
geht's noch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union das ist so
respektlos gegenüber den ärztinnen und
ärzten und das ist respektlos gegenüber
den frauen die diesen schutz brauchen
damit machen wir jetzt schluss meine
damen und herren wir von der fortschritt
koalition machen schluss mit der
unsachlichen
kriminalpolitik der cdu und schluss mit
der bevormundung von frauen wir stehen
für versorgungssicherheit und
selbstbestimmung und wären wir schon
einmal dabei sind freue ich mich auch
schon darauf dass wir uns als ampel noch
so vorgenommen haben erstens machen wir
schwangerschafts abbrüche zum teil der
ärztlichen ausbildung damit mehr
ärztinnen die abbrüche anbieten können
und frauen überall zugang dazu haben
zweitens werden wir die möglichkeiten
schaffen die kosten der schwangerschafts
abbrüche zu übernehmen und drittens
werden wir das system der
schwangerschafts abbrüche im strafrecht
auf den prüfstand stellen denn für uns
steht fest
selbstbestimmung darf kein verbrechen
sein meine damen und auch wirklich
erlauben sie noch alle zwischen oder
nachfrage sind raus und storch
offensichtlich nicht die störche sind
vorbei
es ist quali storchen zeit ich darauf
hinweisen
und ich akzeptiere das ist also die art
die fraktion wünsche eine große nation
frau von storch sie haben jetzt die
möglichkeit sich zu äußern
vielen dank herr präsident dass sie die
intervention zu lassen ich habe eine
frage an frau brandi drehte sich an alle
die die hier für dieses abschaffung des
werbeverbots aufgerichtet haben aber sie
sind jetzt adressiert sie reden alle
über die frauen und das recht der frauen
in extension das einzige was bei ihnen
nie vorkommt ist das ungeborene kind das
findet in ihrer gesamten debatte nicht
statt
und ich möchte gerne von ihnen wissen
ich möchte gerne von ihnen wissen auf
welchem moment sie anerkennen dass das
ungeborene kind ein mensch ist das volle
menschenwürde hat dass ein lebensrecht
hat das leben darf und dass man nicht
mehr antasten darf sagen sie mir ab
welchem monat sie der meinung sind dass
eine abtreibung nicht mehr zulässig sein
soll bis wann
darf ein muss ein ungeborenes kind um
sein leben fürchten und ab wann nach
ihrer anschauung ist das leben des
ungeborenen kindes
lebenswert
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident frau von
storch ich stelle fest dass sie das
thema immer noch nicht verstanden haben
und auch keinen wertvollen beitrag zu
dieser debatte liefern können insoweit
hätte ihre fraktionen ihnen das recht
einräumen können zu dieser debatte zu
diskutieren der beitrag ihres kollegen
seitz hat eigentlich das desinteresse
ihrer fraktion an einer vernünftigen
debatte an diesem punkt deutlich gemacht
und ihre kurzintervention waren nicht
dazu geeignet dass in ein anderes licht
zu rücken deswegen steht für meine
fraktion fest wir werden das thema
weiter sachlich bearbeiten und wir
wollen den lebensschutz
für alle beteiligten durch medizinische
informationen sicherstellen indem wir
den paragrafen 219 anstreichen
vielen dank vorlegen sie haben die frage
beantwortet das mag ihn gibt ja ich
versuche alles zu erklären sie hat sie
hat geantwortet ob sie das mit zufrieden
stellt oder nicht liegt nicht mehr
messen des präsidiums
noch einmal sie hat die frage
beantwortet im rahmen ihrer
möglichkeiten und ja sie hat ja waren
sie doch waren sie also
und von dem von ihm und dem event und im
rahmen dieses verständnis ist insofern
kann man dazu nicht tun nächste gegnerin
ist die kollegin dorothee bär cdu/csu
dazu
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich habe im vorfeld dieser
debatte mir überlegt dass uns sicherlich
heute im haus hier eine gewisse
ernsthaftigkeit 1 und das uns heute hier
auch im haus 1 zu überlegen was ist für
jede einzelne frau was es aber auch für
das ungeborene kind für das ungeborene
leben das wichtigste und es ist eine
debatte die auch wenn man seit vielen
vielen jahren ja schon seit jahrzehnten
hier am rednerpult stehen darf eine sehr
sehr emotional ist und einige keinen
kalt lassen kann und wo es meines
erachtens auch keine einfachen lösungen
gibt und kein richtig und kein falsch
und deswegen war ich tatsächlich
schockiert entsetzt traurig sehr geehrte
frau kollegin weg mit welcher art und
weise sie hier aufgetreten sind
wir hinzustellen und zu sagen ich
genieße es ist ein schöner moment
muss ich wirklich sagen schauen sie sich
ihre rede vielleicht in fünf jahren in
zehn jahren in 15 jahren noch einmal an
erklären sie vielleicht irgendwann haben
ihren kindern was sie heute hier
abgezogen haben es ist wirklich etwas wo
ich sagen muss das ist doch nicht der
geist gehen diese debatte atmen sollte
und wir müssen uns doch auch immer
wieder klar machen wir uns heute zu
schaut uns schauen heute frauen zu
vielleicht mit drei kindern von denen
wir nicht wissen dass sie um überhaupt
diese drei kinder zu bekommen schon sehr
schwangerschaften hinter sich hatten und
schauen frauen die keine kinder bekommen
können ich habe vorher noch mit jemanden
gesprochen die mit 20 jahren das erste
mal das einzige mal auch abgetrieben hat
und jetzt in einer
kinderwunschbehandlung ist das ist sehr
emotional die frau und die uns heute
zuschauen wir schauen uns frauen so die
sternenkinder haben es schauen uns
frauen zu die vielen fehlgeburten hatten
die abtreibungen hinter sich haben die
vielleicht regenbogenkinder haben
deswegen würde ich mich einfach freuen
wenn wir schon über diese debatte heute
sprechen auf der einen seite
vordergründig 219 aber wie es ja auch
deutlich wurde in vielen redebeiträgen
dass es eigentlich um den 218 geht dass
es ein bisschen seriöser hier auch
verstanden gilt
und was mich aufstellen der sonst eher
leben diese frage bitte dann haben sie
eine zwischenfrage aus der fraktion
jetzt nicht was mich auch wahnsinnig
stört ist dass sie es mit fortschritt
begründen mit selbstbestimmung mit
freiheit und das ist so tun als ob wir
auch als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion die
frau nicht in den mittelpunkt stellen
das tun wir in der milch und natürlich
geht es um selbstbestimmung und
natürlich geht es darum dass eine frau
entscheiden kann das kann sie aber und
wir trauen den frau geben auch zu dass
sie sich selber entscheiden können
nachdem sie eine ordentliche beratung
eben auch hinter sich haben weil das
können sie doch auch nicht abstreiten so
einer hoch emotionalen situation muss
jemand die möglichkeit haben mit
jemanden anzusprechen muss jemand die
möglichkeit haben eben auch begründet
werden im anschluss mit dem arzt jahr
aber erstmal eine neutrale beratung in
einer hochemotionalen phase meine
kollegin nina hagen hatte ausgesprochen
meine kollegin hat ja gesagt wie
notwendig das ist das eben auch immer
jemand an der seite der frau ist weil
die frau wird die entscheidung ihr
ganzes leben bei sich tragen egal ob sie
das kind austrägt oder nicht dass muss
man doch immer auch im hinterkopf haben
und ich möchte mich noch mal der meinung
auch von der kollegin wagen anschließend
zu müssen wir können doch so eine
debatte nicht führen in dem kein
einziges mitglieder ampel nicht auch
noch vom kind spricht und wir können das
auch diese debatte nicht stört
wir können doch diese debatte nicht
führen wenn sich jetzt auch was die
strafgesetzbuch und ähnliches betrifft
wenn sich in der lex hätte durchführen
wollen das ist mit uns nicht zu machen
eine ärztin die von zellhausen streben
eine aktie noch nicht mal akzeptiert
dass es ein embryo ist ein werdendes
leben jeder der mal schwanger war jeder
der erfährt dass der schwanger ist bei
seiner frauenärztin bei einem frauenarzt
liegt ein ultraschall bekommen und in
der sechsten woche schon das hat
schlägen sagen hört schon merkt dass da
leben am wachsen ist und dann zu sagen
dass es nur ein zellhaufen und das ist
normaler eingriff wieder andere dass es
mitunter zu tun auf keinen fall zu
machen
und niemand niemand regt so eine
entscheidung leicht kann ich fast
niemand würde ich sagen fast niemand
wenn man sich einige interviews diese
woche durchgelesen hat von jutta
ditfurth und ähnlichen meine zweite
abtreibung war die schönste das lass ich
mal dahin gestellt aber die mehrheit
trifft sie nicht leichtfertig und ich
kann ihnen nur sagen unterstütze sie
unseren antrag wir wollen § 209 10 a
nicht abschaffen wir wollen erhalten wir
wollen ihn verbessern wir wollen weitere
informationsmöglichkeiten für ärztinnen
und ärzte wir wollen ergebnis auch wenn
die beratung wir appellieren an sie als
bundesregierung mit den ländern zu
sprechen dass es eben überall in allen
regionen auch als zehn ärzte gibt wir
wollen rechtliche voraussetzungen dass
auch die kurse mehrheitlich erwartende
der verhütungsmittel übernommen werden
und ich freue mich tatsächlich auch über
eine seriöse weitergehende beratung
möchte aber abschließend trotz an die
beiden minister die heute gesprochen
haben so problemlos letzter satz herr
präsident der buschmann hat das ganze
heute ja sehr sachlich sehr down to
earth 219 hier besprochen rathaus hat
schon in 218 er ins spiel gebracht ich
bin auf die beratungen gespannt und
hoffe dass die bundesregierung das in
einer seriösen art und weise macht bei
uns ist es wahnsinnig wichtig gehen
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende dorothee bär hat
gesprochen noch ein bisschen arbeiten